Ich bin ein ver, ein.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon hier auf Fritz. Findet alle zwei Monate am letzten Donnerstag im Monat statt. Und es ist mal wieder soweit. Und da kommen immer und ich weiß nicht, wie lange das noch so ist Menschen aus dem Chaos Computer Club oder dem näheren Umfeld hierher und erzählen irgendwas mit Technik, Internet, digital, Dinge, die die Welt erobern werden und mit Trump zu tun haben. Und das ist heute sozusagen aktueller das Thema denn je, denn es geht um künstliche Intelligenz. Und dazu begrüße ich ganz recht herzlich Priska.
Guten Abend.
Klee. Tobias Anton. So und die werden uns heute ein bisschen genauer erzählen, was künstliche Intelligenz ist, worüber man da arbeiten muss, was die Fortschritte sind, woran man scheitert und warum man das überhaupt alles macht. Und warum ist das gerade ein Thema? Ihr habt es vielleicht mitbekommen, eine künstliche Intelligenz hat einen Go-Spieler geschlagen. Und Go ist ein Spiel mit schwarzen und weißen Steinen auf einem Spielbrett und dann fragt man sich vielleicht, okay, es ist 2016, war der nicht schon irgendwie in den 90ern? Also kurz nach der Eiszeit irgendwas, das ein Computer einem Menschen geschlagen hat. Was ist das Besondere? Das werden wir heute hier erklären und vor allen Dingen, wie man das macht. Vielleicht, ob man es auch selber programmieren kann. All das klären wir heute. Falls ihr Fragen dazu habt, könnt ihr währenddessen anrufen. 0331 70 97 110. Bevor wir damit aber anfangen, was die künstliche Intelligenz ausmacht, würde ich gerne noch wissen, was die Menschen ausmacht, die heute hier zu Besuch sind. Fangen wir an mit Priska. Hallo, guten Tag. Wie sind Sie zur KI gekommen? Warum machen Sie da was mit?
Ich habe damals, als ich überlegt habe, anzufangen zu studieren, gesucht nach Neurobiologie und maschineller Sprachverarbeitung, weil das mich interessiert hat. Und es gab genau einen Studiengang, in dem das vorkam. Das sind die Kognitionswissenschaften. Und habe das dann studiert. Und ein Teil davon ist eben auch die künstliche Intelligenz. Und ich bin dann, obwohl ich über zwei der Disziplinen reingekommen bin, dann Richtung künstliche Intelligenz wieder rausgegangen und arbeite jetzt in dem Bereich.
Machst du das heute auch noch? Dann ist Clida auch Kognitionswissenschaftler. Und du hast vorher erzählt, du hast das sehr, sehr lange studiert. Was bedeutet das und warum?
Also das bedeutet erst mal, dass ich lange nicht fertig geworden bin. Also ich bin auf eine ganz ähnliche Art dazugekommen wie Priska. Ich habe mir vor dem Studieren irgendwie gedacht, was machst du? Und Kognitionswissenschaft ist halt so eine Mischgeschichte aus Neurobiologie und Psychologie und künstlicher Intelligenz und so weiter. Und irgendwann bin ich dann so richtig auf den Zug aufgesprungen und habe mir gedacht, eigentlich hätte ich gerne eine Maschine, die für mich denkt. Ich denke eigentlich nicht besonders gerne. Ich denke aber gerne drüber nach, wie ich eine Maschine bauen könnte, die das für mich übernimmt. Und dann müsste ich das nicht mehr tun.
Ist das das Endgame, dass du aufhörst zu denken?
Füße hochlegen.
Oder dass du, okay, ich dachte jetzt eher sozusagen die Maschine übernimmt, die die anstrengenden, irgendwie Low-Level Sachen, die uninteressant sind. Du kannst dich dann mit den großen Problemen des Lebens beschäftigen, aber du willst wirklich alles abgeben.
Ich mach dann noch was Spaß macht.
Okay, verstehe, verstehe. Dann haben wir Tobias Anton, Fast Doctor. Wie bist du zur KI gekommen?
Ja, wie bin ich dazu gekommen? Ich habe vor gut zehn Jahren Informatik studiert, das heißt also Datenbanken und Suchverfahren implementieren. Und dann habe ich mich gefragt, ist das alles? Gibt es da nicht irgendwie noch was Besseres? Und habe dann angefangen, mir zu erarbeiten, was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen einem Suchverfahren und einer künstlichen Intelligenz? Und habe dann alle möglichen Peppers gelesen, aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt bis heute keinen Unterschied gefunden.
Okay, wenn wir vielleicht noch genauer drauf zu sprechen kommen. Benthor?
Ja, ich habe einen ähnlichen Wernegang wie Priska. Ich habe allerdings nach dem Bachelor mit der Kognitionswissenschaft aufgehört und dann, wie sich das für einen echten Nerd gehört, ein Jahr Computer Science gemacht und dann habe ich das abgebrochen und dann noch was anderes gemacht. Und ich habe aber das Thema seit dem Abschluss meines Bachelors weiterverfolgt und bin auch ein interessierter Großspieler. Und ich denke, ich kann einiges zum Thema heute Abend beitragen.
Also das heißt, du arbeitest aber nicht in dem Bereich.
Ich arbeite nicht in dem Bereich.
Okay, aber andererseits finde ich das beruhigend, weil das bedeutet auch, dass man sich nicht Vollzeit damit beschäftigen muss, aber trotzdem Dinge verstehen kann.
Das ist so richtig.
Ja, ist eine Chance für mich und alle, die vielleicht jetzt gerade eine neue Artigen Rundfunkempfangsgeräte sind und sich fragen, habe ich überhaupt eine Chance, da irgendwas zu lernen, wenn ich da heute zuhör? Habt ihr? Wir versuchen es natürlich wie immer so zu halten, dass man genau mitkommen kann, wenn man jetzt dabei bleiben will. Und jetzt ist ja das Spannende, wenn man sehr viele Expertenrunden hat, dann ist man irgendwie als Nichtwissende auf der Ansicht, die wissen alle ganz genau, worum es geht und stellt an fest, wenn man die fragt nach einer Meinung, dann haben die irgendwie vier Experten, fünf Meinungen. Ich würde deshalb jetzt von jedem Einzelnen von euch ganz kurz wissen wollen, was ist denn eigentlich künstliche Intelligenz bento?
Wir haben uns tatsächlich im Vorgespräch an das Thema nicht so ganz ran getraut, weil wir alle eine unterschiedliche Meinung hatten.
Okay, dann stelle ich die Frage vielleicht anders, damit ihr euch nicht so doll festlegen müsst. Wir machen heute eine zweistündige Radiosendung über künstliche Intelligenz. Worüber werden wir sprechen?
Wir werden über neuartige Herangehensweisen an Problemlösungen, also an Probleme sprechen. Vor allen Dingen Dinge, die man nicht mehr unbedingt versteht. Also beispielsweise, wie dein Spam-Filter funktioniert, wie ein Auto von alleine fahren kann. Wenn man sich ein bisschen mit Programmierung auseinandergesetzt hat, dann weiß man erst mal nicht, wie man jetzt an die Geschichte rangehen würde. Also es ist intuitiv nicht klar, wie man diese Art von Probleme löst. Und man kann diese Art von Probleme lösen, indem man versucht, Funktionsweisen von biologischen Gehirnen nachzubauen.
Okay, ich halte an dieser Stelle erst mal für mich fest. Künstliche Intelligenz kann zum Beispiel sein, Software, die man nicht mehr versteht. Also die man nicht selber probiert. Aus dramaturgischen Gründen zugespitzt. Wir können gleich noch darauf kommen, inwieweit das vielleicht tatsächlich zutrifft. Tobias, Künstliche Intelligenz, was ist das?
Also Künstliche Intelligenz ist all das, was uns das Denken erleichtert oder abnimmt.
Okay, das finde ich jetzt sehr einfache, weil da würde ich sagen, schon die einfachste Software ist. Müssen wir auch mal genauer darüber reden. Cle, Künstliche Intelligenz, was würdest du sagen, was ist das?
Man könnte sagen, das ist ein Modell des menschlichen Geistes, aber vielleicht geht es noch weiter. Es könnte auch was sein, was sich dann für Selbstständigt und gar nicht mehr so viel mit dem menschlichen Geist zu tun hat, sondern noch besser im Problemlösen ist als wir. Also jetzt habe ich zwei halbe Antworten gegeben.
Also erst mal ist Künstliche Intelligenz ein Teilgebiet der Informatik, das sich damit befasst, intelligente Systeme zu modellieren und zu entwickeln. Das heißt, einerseits versuchen wir, Systeme zu bauen, die vielleicht ähnlich intelligent sind wie der Mensch, andererseits aber auch Modelle zu bauen der menschlichen Intelligenz, um diese besser zu verstehen.
Ah, das klingt fast schon an der wissenschaftlichen Definition nicht schlecht. Deswegen ist das Thema tatsächlich auch nicht nur im Chaosradio, sondern auch in anderen Medien gerade präsent, dass eine Künstliche Intelligenz, so nennt man sie, im Go einen menschlichen Spieler geschlagen hat. Nicht irgendeinen menschlichen Spieler Lee Sedol, das ist der Weltmeister, also der Großmeister, heißt das glaube ich beim Go-Spielen, sogar also jemand, der das wirklich wirklich sehr gut kannt. Und tatsächlich fragt man sich aber, warum ist das so ein großes Ding? Weil es war jetzt die 97, das ist auch ein großer Computer, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man den dann auch kainen würde, aber den Menschen im Schach spielen geschlagen hat, wo man auch damals gesagt hat, ja okay, wenn das passiert ist, dann ist es jetzt so ein Durchbruch. Also was ist der Unterschied zwischen, oder warum ist es jetzt fast 20 Jahre später wieder ein großes Ding, dass eine Maschine einen Menschen in einem Brettspiel schlägt? Was ist der Unterschied? Was ist da passiert? Wer auch immer mir das jetzt beantworten kann.
Also ich glaube, einer der wesentlichen Unterschiede zwischen Deep Blue und AlphaGo ist, dass Deep Blue sehr stark in seinem Verhalten davon geprägt war, von Expertenwissen. Also da haben sich Schachmeister hingesetzt und Regeln geschrieben, nach denen das agiert hat.
Also quasi im Prinzip jeder erdenkliche Zug wurde quasi in ein großes Buch, in eine große Datenbank geschrieben und hat das Programm während des Spiels einfach nur nachgeschlagen. Okay, jetzt sieht das Brett gerade so aus, was könnte daraus folgen oder wie?
Ganz genau, die Details kenne ich nicht, aber ich stelle es mir auch so ungefähr vor. Der wesentliche Unterschied zu AlphaGo ist jetzt, dass AlphaGo zwar auch auf menschlichen Go-Spielen trainiert wurde, aber dem hat man einfach diese Go-Spiele vorgesetzt und nicht explizit irgendwelche Regeln mitgegeben, sondern diese Muster, die es da zu erkennen gibt, hat es selber gelernt.
Okay, das ist schon der Punkt, wo ich aussteige. Wie macht es das? Man hat einen Computer und der hat eine Kamera, guckt auf das Brett und sagt dann, lerne Go alleine? Oder was passiert da?
Also es gibt mehrere Verfahren, die da eingesetzt wurden. Das hat keine Kamera, mit der das auf den Computer guckt. Könnte man aber machen. Aber man kann auch einfach als Matrix quasi dem das Spielbrett geben. Dann hat man da irgendwie Zahlen stehen, wo schwarze Steine sind und andere Zahlen, wo weiße Steine sind. Und dann eins der Verfahren ist sogenanntes überwachtes maschinelles Lernen. Da gibt man ihnen ein Brett und sagt, bitte sagt den nächsten guten Zug vorher und gibt ihm aber die richtige Lösung danach mit und passt dann die Parameter des Netzwerkes an, sodass es die richtige Lösung lernt.
Also da lernt Software tatsächlich selber Dinge. Kann man das so sagen?
Genau, also man hat Algorithmen geschrieben, die basierend auf dieser Eingabe, du liest folgendes Muster und das ist ein guter Zug gewesen. Man hat Software geschrieben, die dann hingeht und basierend auf der Information, dass das jetzt ein guter Zug war, intern in dieser künstlichen Intelligenz Parameter ändert, sodass wenn diese künstliche Intelligenz diesen einen ähnlichen Zug demnächst nochmal machen soll, dass sie dann mit erhöhten Wahrscheinlichkeit dann den als gut gelernten Zug nimmt.
Eigentlich ist es genau andersrum. Die Software ändert ihre Gewichte eigentlich nur, wenn ein schlechter Zug gemacht wurde. Also so kenne ich es.
Okay, ich sehe das eher als ein Detail. Also prinzipiell reagiert die Software algorithmisch auf gelernte Unterscheidungsklassen zwischen das war ein guter Zug und das war ein schlechter Zug. Und natürlich irgendwie, was du jetzt so eher beschrieben hast, wäre eine Art bestrafen. Also die Software hat gerade einen schlechten Zug gemacht. Bitte ändere deinen internen Zustand so um, dein Entscheidungsnetzwerk, lassen wir es mal so bezeichnen, so um, dass dieser schlechte Zug dir mit einer viel geringeren Wahrscheinlichkeit in der Zukunft noch mal passiert oder nicht mehr vorkommt.
Also der Unterschied ist, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, bei dem Schachtdingen hat man vorher mehr oder weniger festgelegte Anzahl oder einen Katalog aufgestellt. Hier hat die Maschine es selber gelernt. Aber ist es jetzt bei beiden noch so? Im Prinzip irgendwann ist das Ding fertig und spielt dann damit. Also schlägt es während es tatsächlich spielt nur nach. Oder ist das Neue jetzt, dass der AlphaGo Computer tatsächlich während des Spiels auch noch Dinge gelernt hat, also tatsächlich reagiert hat auf den Menschen und nicht nur nachgeschlagen hat?
Nein, es ist möglich, dass AlphaGo das auch kann. Das war aber nicht das Bemerkenswerte an der Geschichte, sondern das Bemerkenswerte an der Geschichte war, ist das verglichen mit dem Schachcomputer von 1997 war das, glaube ich, hat kann AlphaGo selbstständig gelernt, die richtigen Muster zu erkennen. Natürlich hat man da auch einen Go-Experten dran gesetzt, der diesem AlphaGo dann auch Spielzüge vorgesetzt hat, welches es dann gelernt hat, aber das Netzwerk, was da jetzt gerade gegen diesen Großmeister gewonnen hat, hat diese entscheidende Fähigkeit verallgemeinern zu können und selbst Züge, die es nicht explizit gelernt hat, anhand von den Mustern, die aber aus diesem Lernprozess entstanden sind, auszuführen.
Es ist denn jetzt so, dass es auch noch Rolle spielt, dass das Go ist, weil man hätte sagen können, okay, jetzt haben wir sozusagen Schach auf die eine Art gelernt, dann kann man auch noch Schach auf die andere Art lernen und schlagen wir einfach nochmal einen Schachmeister mit diesem neuen Ding. Oder ist Go noch mal eine andere Klasse von Spiel, weil es irgendwie, keine Ahnung, komplizierter ist oder irgendwas? Beides.
Also Go ist von den Regeln her deutlich simpler als Schach. Und die Komplexität des Spiels ergibt sich nur aus den vielen verschiedenen Möglichkeiten, die diese einfachen Regeln zulassen. Also auf einem Go-Brett, das funktioniert im Prinzip so, dass man ein Gitter hat und man kann, man hat zwei Farben von Steinen und der eine Spieler hat schwarze Steine und der andere hat die weißen Steine. Und abwechselnd setzt jeder Spieler Steine auf dieses Gitter. Und die einzige Regel, die, die, die einzige wichtige Regel dabei ist, dass man an benachbarten Steinen, an benachbarten Punkten auf diesem.
Brett Das Spiel ist so kompliziert, dass die Menschen sozusagen Probleme haben.
Also es gibt eine Einschränkung beim Setzen. Man darf einen Stein nur auf ein Feld setzen, das mindestens einen Nachbarn hat, der nicht von einem gegnerischen Stein besetzt ist. Und umgekehrt, wenn man durch das Setzen seines Steins einen gegnerischen Stein oder eine Menge von gegnerischen Steinen so umzingelt, dass sie keine Freiheiten mehr haben, wie man das so schön nennt, dann werden diese Steine entfernt.
Und dann geht es darum, dass man möglichst alle Steine des Gegners entfernt?
Nein, es geht um Gebietsgewinnen sozusagen. Es wird hinterher gezählt, wie viel Gebiet habe ich quasi, kontrolliere ich durch meine umzingelten Steine. Also stelle ich meine Steine da. Und bei Go wird nichts gezogen, es werden nur Steine gesetzt. Aber du hast dafür bei jedem einzelnen Zug, das wird in einer typischer Weise auf 19 mal 19 Gittern gespielt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemand mal schnell ausrechnen kann, wie viel.
Wenn ihr das Mikrofon aufmachen müsst, wenn ihr reinruft, dann kann man es auch draußen hören.
Was war das? 361 vermutlich? Oder wolltest du 10 auch 170 wissen?
Nein, ich wollte 361 Züge wissen. Und diese Zahl schrumpft halt pro gemachten Zug nur um einen. Natürlich muss man auch die ganzen Regeln berücksichtigen. Es gibt dann Situationen, wo man an einem gewissen Stelle sich nicht selbst einschränken darf und da keinen Stein hinsetzen darf. Aber dadurch kann ich schon zwei Züge in die Zukunft nicht mehr vernünftig vorhersägen. Weil ich hab halt dann 300, wie war das? 361 Züge mal 361 Züge.
360 Züge natürlich, ja.
Wir hatten fest, richtig viele. Richtig viele. Das ist auch der wichtige Unterschied beim Schach, weil da kann ich zumindest aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, dass man so irgendwie drei bis vier Züge zumindest grob vorherplanen kann. Aber das ist beim Go anstrengend nicht der Fall. Also haben wir schon festgehalten, KI kann was, nämlich Go verstehen und tatsächlich auch gewinnen, was viel komplizierter ist, als ich mir das eigentlich vorgestellt hätte. Jetzt habt ihr aber im, ja?
Aber eigentlich ist es nur ein Suchverfahren. Also das, was die KI beim Go machen soll, die Formulierung des Problems, ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Finde den Stein, der meine Gewinnwahrscheinlichkeit maximiert. Also finde den besten nächsten Zug. Und das Problem, mit dem man sich als Informatiker der heutigen Zeit konfrontiert sieht, ist, dass es einfach unglaublich viele Züge gibt. Es gibt eben nicht nur diese 361, sondern es gibt also insgesamt an Stellungen auf dem Go-Brett eine Anzahl. Das ist eine Zahl mit 170 Stellen. Ich lese die jetzt nicht vor, aber allein diese Zahl der möglichen Stellungen zu berechnen, da hat man eine Weile dafür gebraucht. Und die Anzahl möglicher Endstellungen irgendwie alle durchzurechnen, ist utopisch. Also alle Computer der Welt könnten das in der vermuteten Lebensdauer des Universums nicht. Und deswegen ist man gezwungen, mit Pi mal Daumen-Abschätzung irgendwo was zu machen, was wahrscheinlich funktioniert, aber nicht sicher der beste Zug ist.
Und an der Stelle hast du die wesentliche Unterschied zu dem Schachcomputer, der tatsächlich halt sein großes Schachzug-Wörterbuch drin hatte. Du kannst das bei Go halt einfach nicht mehr machen.
Okay, das wollte ich gerade fragen. Schach war relativ viele Figuren, für Menschen ist es kompliziert. Aber theoretisch mit genug Rechenkraft kann man einfach seinen geneerdecklichen Zug vorhersagen.
Ich glaube ich nicht, aber es sind Größenordnungen dazwischen. Also diese Zahl, diese zwei mit den 170 Nullen dahinter, das ist eine wirklich große Zahl. Es gibt glaube ich im Universum eine zwei mit 80 Nullen an Atomen und das sind eben noch mal doppelt so viele Nullen dahinter.
Aber was sind die Zahlen im Vergleich beim Schach? Habt ihr die auch?
Ich glaube es ist 10 hoch 90.
Okay, ist ein bisschen weniger. Nur noch mal kurz die Frage, die Hardware spielt überhaupt irgendeine Rolle? Also ist der Computer, kann der jetzt mehr? Hat der einen geileren Prozessor als Deep Blue? Oder ist die Hardware mittlerweile total egal und es geht nur um die Algorithmen oder ist das schon auch noch?
Die Hardware, die sie verwendet haben, war ziemlich krass. Also es waren über 1200 CPUs und ich glaube 178 GPUs, auf denen sie gerechnet haben. Wir haben mal versucht so zu schätzen, das ist mehr als ein Megawatt.
Und ein Megawatt sind so ungefähr...
1.2, 1 Gigawatt.
Wie viel verbraucht Berlin oder womit kann man das vergleichen?
Also man kann das vergleichen. Wenn ich mich jetzt nicht um eine Stelle vertan habe, sind ein Megawatt ungefähr die Leistung von zehn Mittelklassewagen, die volle Power machen. Okay. Die Motorene Leistung von zehn Mittelklassewagen müssten ein Megawatt sein, wenn ich mich nicht verrechnet habe.
Da kann man schon ein bisschen was mit machen.
Ich würde gerne noch was dazu sagen, weil bei AlphaGo gab es zwei Versionen. Es gab eine Version, die auf einer starken Maschine gerechnet hat und es gab eine verteilte Version, die mit den Zahlen, die ich gerade genannt habe. Da hing es tatsächlich krass mit der Stärke des Programms zusammen, weil du einfach mit einer viel größeren Maschine viel mehr Simulationen fahren kannst und dadurch zu einem besseren Ergebnis kommst. Eins auf einer großen Maschine könnte mich im Go vermutlich noch besiegen, aber bei Lee Sedol hätte das nicht gereicht.
Ah ok, interessant. Jetzt wissen wir sozusagen, was KI kann, aber ihr habt auch gesagt, am Anfang müssen wir eigentlich auch ein bisschen darüber reden, was KI nicht kann, wo sie sagen Fehler hingelegt hat. Fails, wie es im Internet so schon heißt. Welche sind das und vor allen Dingen, warum sind die wichtig? Also was zu sagen, woran ist KI gescheitert heutzutage? Großes Kopf schütteln? Sind wir mit dem Scheitern der KI gescheitert?
Also das prominentes Gegenbeispiel dieser Tage ist wahrscheinlich die TieAI, die von einem Tastaturhersteller aus Redmond veröffentlicht wurde.
Um Verwirrung zu verhindern, es geht um Microsoft.
Und was Microsoft gut kann, sind Betriebssysteme. Nein, was sie gut können, sind Tastaturen. Bei Betriebssystemen ist man sich nicht so sicher. Und jetzt haben sie sich halt an der Königsdisziplin versucht und wirklich versucht einen sozial interagierenden Bot zu bauen, der mehr kann als nachplappern. Und da sind sie also gescheitert, könnte man sagen.
Inwiefern? Also was hat dieser Bot gemacht? Hat er irgendwie gechattet mit Leuten oder hat er sich im Facebook-Profil zugelegt? Oder wie ist das gelaufen?
Ja, der hat getwittert. Also der hat in der Öffentlichkeit mit Leuten interagiert und hat auch versucht von denen zu lernen und auf die irgendwo einzugehen. Und die Internet-Community hat es anscheinend innerhalb von Tagen geschafft, ihn in einen sabbernden Hater zu verwandeln.
Heißt, der hat dann, worüber hat er dann gesprochen?
Ja, der hat dann halt so das gemacht, was der typische Facebook-User macht. Also er hat irgendwie gehatet. Also ist zu einem Nazi-Arschloch geworden.
Und Anti-Feministen und Trump-Befürworter und derartige Dinge. Ich glaube, du hattest auch irgendwelche beispielhaften Tweets rausgesucht davon.
Vor allem hat er sich auch selber widersprochen. Das ist ja eigentlich das Schöne, wenn du es im Internet schaffst, irgendwie so einen Troll zu entlarven, indem du ihn dazu bringst, sich selber zu widersprechen. Und das haben die Leute also mit diesem Ding innerhalb von einem Tag geschafft.
Aber ich muss ja fragen, ist das wirklich ein Fehlschlag der KI? Weil was ja passiert ist, man setzt einen nackte oder KI, die nichts weiß, irgendwo hin und sagt, lern mal von den Leuten, die zu dir kommen. Wenn man dann den Input nur denen gibt, ist es dann fair zu sagen, dass es ein Fehlschlag, dass sie zum Hater geworden ist, wenn sie einfach nur Haten gelernt hat und nichts anderes?
Absolut nicht. Sie ist einfach nur schlecht erzogen.
Also sagen, das ist sozusagen eigentlich kein Fehlschlag in der KI, sondern ein PR-Desaster für die Firma?
Ja, also einmal ist es ein PR-Desaster für Microsoft. Ich meine, man kann das natürlich auch nachvollziehen, dass diverse Trolle haben dann halt einfach angefangen, diesen Bot mit Nonsens zu füttern oder mit halt Polemik. Aber wie sich halt herausstellt, was Menschen haben dem mal hinterher recherchiert, dass dieser Bot tatsächlich große Anteile von Tweets, die es irgendwo von anderen Leuten gesehen hat, einfach wieder ausgespuckt hat. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das Ding selbst neue Sätze gebaut hat, also maximal selbst neue Lebenssätze gebaut. Aber es hat quasi diese ganzen Datenbasis von Twitter lediglich hergenommen und daraus gesucht, wer antwortet auf welche Wörter was. Was wird auf welche Key Phrases, also Schlüsselsätze, geantwortet und hat dann mehr oder weniger nur Copy-Paste betrieben.
Aber da muss ich mich jetzt verwirrt, weil es gab ja vor einem halben Jahr gab es diesen Gag, dass sich jeder User auf seinem eigenen Rechner so einen kleinen Twitter-Bot gebaut hat, der genau das gemacht hat, nämlich einfach sozusagen die eigene Twitter-Timeline auseinandergenommen hat und dann so Halbversatzstücke gemacht. Ist das das nur in groß?
Genau, die Vermutung ist, dass es genau das nur in groß ist, dass Microsoft hat halt irgendwo von Twitter einfach mal so eine große Pipeline an Live-Tweets vermutlich abgegriffen und darauf diesen Bot trainiert. Der Bot ist angeschaltet worden und hat dann auf den Live-Dingen alle trainiert. Also der Bot hat innerhalb von, was war das, einer Stunde 80.000 verschiedene Konversationen gehabt, wenn ich mich nicht irre. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Stunde stimmt, aber so innerhalb von den Röstenordnungsmäßig. Und hat dann einfach angefangen, weil wir dann einzelne Tweets gefunden haben, die so Wort für Wort inklusive Rechtschreibfehler von anderen Menschen kopiert wurden.
Was ich an der ganzen Geschichte sehr interessant finde, ist, warum betrachtet man das als Fehlschlag? Weil an dieser Frage können wir erkennen, woran machen wir eigentlich Intelligenz fest? Das ist ja eine Sache, die haben wir bisher ausgeklammert. Die Definition, was ist eigentlich Intelligenz? Also wir können viel über künstliche Intelligenz reden, aber es gibt keine allgemeingültige Definition von Intelligenz. Da gibt es verschiedene Maße, die meisten kommen von Psychologen. Aus psychologischer Sicht ist der Teil deswegen interessant, weil wir sagen, das ist ein Idiot, weil der sich selbst widerspricht. Das heißt, damit ein Mensch, einen ihm gegenüber wie auch immer geartet als intelligent betrachtet, muss der einen Standpunkt vertreten, der für den Rezipienten nachvollziehbar und konsistent ist. Und das ist eine Anforderung, die kann künstliche Intelligenz nur sehr schwer erfüllen. Also eine, die in Go jeden Spieler schlagen kann, hat doch ihre Schwierigkeiten, damit eben so die Öffentlichkeit mit einem Bild von sich zu versorgen, das der Öffentlichkeit irgendwie schmeckt.
Da würde ich aber gerne sofort widersprechen. Also ich vermute, die meisten Menschen, denen ich begegne, sind in irgendeiner Art und Weise widersprüchlich. Es kann sein, dass sie sich sehr darum sorgen, diese Widersprüche aufzulösen. Aber das per se ist für mich noch kein Zeichen dafür, dass mein Gegenüber nicht intelligent ist. Mir passiert das auf jeden Fall öfter mal, dass ich mir selbst widerspreche und dann das feststelle und denke, okay, vielleicht kann ich es auflösen.
Das ist sehr interessant, weil die Frage ist, wenn man noch nicht mal genau weiß, was Intelligenz ist oder noch nicht genau definiert hat, ist die Frage, wie baut man es nach und was will man erreichen. Das klären wir dann gleich. Vorher gibt es aber erst mal die Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und dann geht es weiter hier im Chaosradio im Blue Moon.
Am 16. August kommen wie jeden Tag tausende Besucher nach Berlin. Aber unter denen ist eine ganz besondere Berlin Besucherin. Denn sie steht an diesem Tag vor tausenden live auf der Bühne.
Let's präsentieren.
Der Terrorverdächtige Abduslam kann von Belgien nach Frankreich ausgeliefert werden.
Das hat ein Untersuchungsgericht in Brüssel entschieden. Der 26-jährige Franzose war vor knapp zwei Wochen in der belgischen Hauptstadt verhaftet worden. Er soll bei den Terroranschlägen von Paris im November geholfen haben und war vier Monate lang auf der Flucht.
Bei den Attentaten wurden 130 Menschen getötet. Abduslams Anwalt sagte, dass sein Mandant mit der Auslieferung einverstanden ist und mit den französischen Behörden zusammenarbeiten wird. Der Flughafen in Brüssel kann nach den Anschlägen vor anderthalb Wochen wieder öffnen. Der Betreiber teilte mit, dass die ersten Passagiermaschinen übermorgen starten und landen sollen, das müssten die Behörden aber noch genehmigen. Am Brüsseler Flughafen hatten sich vergangene Woche zwei Selbstmordattentäter in die Luft gesprengt.
Dabei wurde die Abflughalle stark beschädigt.
Außerdem gab es einen Anschlag auf eine U-Bahn. Insgesamt kamen 32 Menschen ums Leben.
Am Montag sollen die ersten 500 Flüchtlinge von Griechenland in die Türkei zurückgeschickt werden.
Das sagten Mitarbeiter der EU-Kommission in Brüssel. Damit würde der umstrittene Flüchtlingspakt mit der Türkei wie geplant umgesetzt werden.
Demnach sollen alle Flüchtlinge, die seit dem 20.
März in Griechenland angekommen sind, in die Türkei abgeschoben werden. Das Land bekommt dafür mehrere Milliarden Euro. Außerdem sollen Flüchtlinge aus Lagern in der Türkei legal in die EU übersiedeln können. Schwere Menschenrechtsverletzungen im BM-Land Katar. Dazu hat Amnesty International der FIFA noch mal schwere Vorwürfe gemacht. In einem Bericht der Menschenrechtsorganisation heißt es, Tausende Arbeiter würden auf den Baustellen ausgebeutet. In einigen Fällen könne man sogar von Zwangsarbeit sprechen.
Amnesty wirft dem Fußball-Weltverband vor, zu wenig dagegen zu tun.
Die FIFA reagierte zurückhaltend und erklärte, man wisse zwar von den Zuständen auf den Baustellen, Vertraue Katar aber.
Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Pankow sind's 8 Grad und in Tempelhof 9 Grad, Forst meldet 7 Grad, Prenzlau 8 Grad und in Brandenburg an der Havel und Brücks sind's 9 Grad.
In der Nacht bleibt's bewölkt und im Süden von Brandenburg regnet es.
Die Temperaturen gehen dann auf 5 bis 2 Grad runter. Der Tag morgen wird netter als heute. Morgens kann noch etwas Regen runterkommen, danach ist es aber überall sonnig und trocken bei maximal 13 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, B96, Berlin Tiergarten und Moabit im Tiergartentunnel zwischen Kämperplatz und Invalidenstraße blockiert ein kaputtes Auto die rechte Spur.
Und nach Brandenburg, 1140 Nuthestraße, Starnsdorf Richtung Potsdam.
In der Ausfahrt Horstbeck ist die Feuerwehr im Einsatz, fahrt hier also bitte besonders vorsichtig.
Eine Meldung noch zu S-Bahn Berlin. Nach einem Polizeieinsatz in Köpenick fahren die Bahnen auf der Linie S3 zu spät oder fallen ganz aus.
Da, wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz für die Hosentasche wollt, mit Livestream, Studio Message, Podcasts und jede Menge mehr, dann holt euch doch die Fritz App.
Kostenlos und werbefrei in eurem App oder Play Store.
Heute Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und zu Gast sind vom Chaos Computer Club und dem näheren weiteren Umfeld Priska, Klee, Tobias und Bento. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Und wir sprechen heute über künstliche Intelligenz. Haben in der ersten halben Stunde erklärt, warum wir darüber sprechen, weil nämlich eine künstliche Intelligenz einen Großmeister im Go geschlagen hat und auch schon ein bisschen erfahren, was daran schiefgehen kann. Microsoft hat versucht, eine künstliche Intelligenz zu bauen, die twittert und die ist zum Hater geworden, was ist jetzt nicht so der dolle Erfolg geworden. Das habe aber auch da schon ein bisschen gelernt. Naja, ist gar nicht so einfach zu sagen, was denn Intelligenz eigentlich ist und wie man die dann letztendlich umsetzt. Ihr hattet aber, bevor wir dazu dazu kommen, noch zwei KI-Fehlschläge, die ihr sagen wolltet. Das eine ist, eine KI fährt gegen einen LKW. Was ist da passiert und warum ist das lustig oder was kann man daraus lernen?
Ja, das war also aus der Zeit, wo Volvo versucht hat, Bremsassistenten zu entwickeln. Das heißt dann Zielbremsung. Da geht es darum, dass eine Kamera oder ein Radarsensor ein Hindernis erkennt und einen Blechschaden vermieden wird, indem die Bremse reingehauen wird, wenn man das für angemessen hält. Und die sind also aufs Testgelände gefahren, haben auch Reporter eingeladen zu der ganzen Geschichte, haben dann das Fahrzeug beschleunigt auf eine bestimmte Geschwindigkeit und wollten dann einfach zeigen, dass es bei dem LKW abbremst. Aber es hat irgendeinen Fehler gegeben, es hat nicht gebremst und ist dann da voll draufgefahren. Es gibt noch ein zweites, man darf das auch nicht verwechseln, es gibt noch ein zweites, da haben irgendwelche Leute versucht, diese Personenbremsung, also eine Personenerkennung auch mit automatischer Zielbremsung auszutesten und die sind dann überfahren worden. Der Hintergrund davon war aber, dass bei dem Auto, dass eine Mehrausstattung war, eine kostenpflichtige und die ist nicht geordert gewesen. Also das ist ein typischer Human-Fail gewesen. Der eigentliche Fall von Darwin Award.
Da gab es doch irgendwas mit Bier und Windeln?
Ja.
Was hat das mit KI zu tun?
Das ist ein schönes Beispiel aus der Zeit, wo alle so dieses Collaborative Filtering entdeckt haben. Also wo alle gesagt haben, wo alle versucht haben, Amazon gleich zu tun und eben diese Warmkorp-Analyse eingeführt haben. Und da gab es das Beispiel, dass Walmart seine Supermarktkassendaten ausgewertet haben. Und die haben halt ganz plausible Patterns entdeckt. Aber da war eben auch eins dabei, da haben sie sich so ein bisschen gewundert. Und zwar haben die festgestellt, dass wenn jemand Windeln kauft, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er Bier kauft, stark erhöht. Und da hat man sich dann angefangen, Sorgen zu machen, ja was verfüttern die frisch gebackenen Väter ihren Kindern da eigentlich? Und als man sich das angeguckt hat, da hat man halt einfach gesehen, dass der Hintergrund davon einfach ein Ritual ist. Also wenn jemand, wenn ein Mann in Amerika ein Kind kriegt, dann kauft er einmal für seine Frau und für sein Kind die Windeln, danach macht das die Frau. Aber an diesem Abend, wenn das Kind auf die Welt kommt, dann weiß er, also er soll irgendwie seiner Frau die Windeln mitbringen, damit die das dann machen kann. Und er will natürlich mit seinen Kumpels ein Bier trinken. Deswegen landeten in den Warenkörben oft Bier und Windeln gleichzeitig.
Klassische Rollenbilder analysiert durch Walmart-Kassen, sehr interessant. Das ist aber eigentlich kein Fehler. Was mich aber gerade bei beiden Sachen in Frage ist, warum ist denn das KI? Also warum sprechen wir jetzt bei KI drüber? Weil bei beiden, also sowohl dieses eine, ja okay, wenn Leute Bier kaufen, kaufen sie was. Das würde ich jetzt denken, das ist eine normale Datenanalyse. Also ohne jetzt genau zu wissen, was normal ist. Aber ich würde jetzt nicht so ein Label drauf packen. Und auch bei dem Volvo denke ich so, eine Kamera, die erkennt das im Gegensatz, was ist denn daran KI? Und dann steht sie mir die Frage, was ist eigentlich KI? Also was genau wird da versucht, wenn KI gebaut wird? Was versucht man da und wie macht man das?
Also wenn man an eine deutsche Uni geht, dann findet man ziemlich viele Statistiker und Informatiker, die sagen, dass sie KI machen. Weil das halt gerade das Wort ist, was sehr in Mode ist, um diese Datenanalyse-Techniken auch zu beschreiben. Aber wenn wir wirklich über Intelligenz reden wollen, wenn wir haben wollen, dass es irgendwie was beeindruckendes macht und nicht einfach nur irgendwelche statistischen Zusammenhänge findet, dann muss man es irgendwie enger definieren. Dann muss man vielleicht haben, dass das Ding selber lernt oder sogar selber rausfindet, was es lernen muss, um eine bestimmte Aufgabe zu lösen. Das könnte eine Komponente sein.
Das ist fast schon eine metaphysische Zauberfrage. Ist es denn das Ergebnis von KI, soll das sein, dass ein Mensch das Ergebnis, was aus so einer Software herausfällt, nicht mehr sozusagen anders erklären kann, als zu sagen, die denkt jetzt irgendwie? Oder ist das Ziel tatsächlich, eine Software zu schaffen, die selber denken kann, was auch immer das dann bedeutet?
Also ich muss nicht unbedingt haben, dass ich das System am Ende nicht mehr verstehen kann. Das ist ja dann immer auch was Bedrohliches, wenn es nicht mehr nachvollziehbar ist, was das System macht. Es gibt diesen Effekt, den du ansprichst, dass immer wenn so ein System dann verstehbar ist, wenn die Experten also wissen, was da passiert ist, dass das System dann nicht mehr als künstliche Intelligenz bezeichnet wird, sondern als ganz normale Informatik. Das überrascht den... Suchverfahren, genau. Genau, du bist genauso einer, der dann sagt, das ist ja nur... Aber das muss ich nicht unbedingt als Kriterium haben. Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass es möglich ist, eine Intelligenz zu bauen, die man dann trotzdem noch versteht. Das wäre sehr gut. Dann wäre die künstliche Intelligenz gleichzeitig psychologisch interessant.
Das heißt aber, es ist momentan sozusagen schon noch getrennt, dass man sozusagen einerseits versucht, irgendwie die menschliche Intelligenz zu verstehen und das über eine technische Annäherung macht und andererseits versucht, irgendwie komplexe Systeme zu bauen, die uns Aufgaben abnehmen kann, von denen wir vermuten, da muss man intelligent für sein.
Das ist ziemlich getrennt. Das sind ganz verschiedene Gruppen von Leuten, die das auch machen. Also es gibt viel mehr Leute, zum Beispiel Google insgesamt, aber auch viele an den Universitäten. Es gibt viel mehr Leute, die konkrete, ingenieursmäßige Probleme lösen wollen mit diesen Techniken. Und das Interesse an diesen künstlichen Systemen, was über den menschlichen Geist zu lernen, ist nachrangig für die Allermeisten.
Und könnt ihr dann jetzt sozusagen an dieser Stelle so einen Überblick geben, woran da konkret geforscht wird? Kann man das?
Bei den Ingenieuren oder bei den Technikpsychologen?
Nein, bei den Ingenieuren sozusagen. Also alle Beispiele, die wir jetzt hatten, waren ja irgendwie sozusagen, man baut eine Software, die soll dann irgendwas machen.
Also die selbstfahrenden Autos sind zum Beispiel so ein Klassiker.
Das aber gelöst inzwischen.
Inwiefern? Was heißt das ist gelöst?
Autos können alleine fahren. Also es ist technisch möglich, ein selbstfahrendes Auto zu bauen, das dich von A nach B bringt, das selbst in die Garage einparkt, das selbst durch den Stadtverkehr findet.
Ich hatte ja gehofft, ihr könnt mir ein bisschen so sagen, wir können eine Ebene tiefer gehen und ihr erklärt, was passiert da?
Also eine Neuerung, und wenn ich sage Neuerung, dann sind das immer 30 Jahre alte Techniken, bei denen man jetzt langsam rausgefunden hat, wie man sie verwenden muss, damit sie funktionieren. Aber eine wesentliche Neuerung ist, dass man jetzt so langsam Systeme hat, denen man nicht mehr genau alle Antworten vorgibt, die sie ausspucken müssen, sondern man sagt ihnen nur, ob sie das gerade richtig oder falsch gemacht haben. Und die suchen sich dann selber die Zusammenhänge in der Umwelt raus. Die sie brauchen, um es beim nächsten Mal besser zu machen. Es ist also inzwischen viel mehr so, als ob man einem Hund Tricks beibringt, als eine Maschine programmiert.
Aber wie funktioniert das? Das ist die Magie. Ich dachte, das ist der Punkt, warum wir heute zusammen hier sind. Dass man ein bisschen diese Magie wegnimmt. Also mir ist klar, dass wir jetzt irgendwie nicht ein Grundstudio mit künstlicher Intelligenzprogramm machen können. Aber was ist der Trick, was passiert da?
Man kann das erklären, du möchtest das erklären oder wie?
Ja, ich würde mal versuchen, einen Ansatz zu wagen. Im Grunde baue ich so ein System, in dem ich ihm immer Daten eingebe. Wenn ich jetzt Vektor sage, steigen alle aus. Also so ein Datensatz, der besteht aus mehreren Informationseinheiten. Und dann sage ich ihm noch, das ist irgendwie plus oder das ist minus. Ja, Spam oder nicht Spam oder ja, was auch immer. Und ich gebe ihm dann einfach eine Sequenz von solchen Daten. Und jedes dieser Datenelemente hat eben ein sogenanntes Label. Das ist also grün oder blau oder Spam oder nicht Spam. Es können auch mehrere Kategorien sein. Und am Ende bildet das System sich ein Modell, wie das so schön heißt, in dem es versucht, Ähnlichkeiten zwischen den Daten zu finden, die das eine Label haben und Ähnlichkeiten zu finden zwischen den Daten, die das andere Label haben. Und dann versucht es eben, die Unterschiede zwischen diesen Ähnlichkeiten herauszufinden. Und das ist dann halt das Modell, das wir gelernt haben.
Und das tut man algorithmisch. Also das passiert, kann man automatisieren. Man hat sich schlaue Algorithmen ausgedacht, die sich diese Datensätze hernehmen können.
Die sind eigentlich ganz einfach. Du bildest einfach zum Beispiel den Mittelwert aus allen Daten, die das eine Label haben, den Mittelwert aus allen Daten, die das andere Label haben und ziehst dann quasi die Strecken halbierende zwischen den beiden, die gerade zwischen den beiden und in der Mitte dann ein Lotter drauf. Und dann hast du schon mal einen Klassifikator. Also das ist dann einfach eine Ebene durchgelegt, die diese beiden Punktwolken irgendwo voneinander trennt. So, das ist der einfachste Ansatz. Und das gibt es in unzähligen Flavors, in unzähligen Varianten, in unzähligen Abstufungen. Und was jetzt bei diesem Reinforcement Learning passiert ist, dass man eben in diesem Ansatz den Klee erzählt hat, dass ich das System eine Reihe von Schritten machen lasse und ich gebe ihm nach jedem Schritt oder auch nach nicht jedem Schritt einfach ein Feedback. Es ist gerade auf dem richtigen Weg oder nicht auf dem richtigen Weg. Da wird also Folgendes gemacht, dann versucht man diese Positiv- oder Negativbewertung auf die vergangenen Schritte zurück zu projizieren. Und je weiter der Schritt zurückliegt, umso niedriger ist das Gewicht. Also das wird auch wieder zurückgeführt auf dieses ursprüngliche Prinzip. Ich habe Datensätze, die haben ein Plus oder ein Minus dran und ich bilde darüber irgendwo einen Mittelwert. Die Statistik dahinter ist komplizierter, aber das Prinzip ist immer dasselbe.
Aber das heißt eigentlich sozusagen, dass man die Welt, wie auch immer man die definiert, immer in 0 und 1 einteilt und dann daraufhin gehende Entscheidungen trifft in Zukunft?
Nicht zwangsläufig. Also du kannst auch noch mehr Kategorien wählen. Das System ist da nicht darauf beschränkt, was sich unser eins zum Beispiel intuitiv erschließt. Also wenn der Mensch hat eher so die Intuition, so wenig Kategorien wie möglich zu verwenden und das System ist nicht inhärent darauf beschränkt, genau diese Kategorien zu verwenden. Und das ist auch dann der Aspekt, wo es ein bisschen gruselig wird, wenn du dem System sagst, so hier klassifiziere meine E-Mail, irgendwie suche dir halt irgendwelche Gruppierungen zusammen, die für dich Sinn ergeben, und dann guckst du da hinterher drauf und kannst dann eine Gruppe nicht von der anderen unbedingt unterscheiden, weil beispielsweise das System bei der E-Mail nur darauf erkannt hat, ob das Ganze jetzt von einer.com E-Mail Adresse oder.org E-Mail Adresse kommt zum Beispiel. Das ist ein Ding, ein Parameter, nachdem das System gelernt hat, zu unterscheiden. Wir haben dem System gesagt, bitte unterscheide jetzt mal, egal, wonach. Hinter guckt man drauf und sieht, es ergibt nicht wirklich Sinn. An der Stelle wird dann die künstliche Intelligenz tendenziell gruselig, wenn es Klassifizierungen wählt, die der Mensch nicht mehr versteht.
Und die trotzdem aber noch Sinn machen?
Wie ich gerade sagte, wenn du genau genug draufschaust, dann findest du irgendwelche Dinge. Wie zum Beispiel das mit dem Bier und dem Windeln. Da musste man ganz genau hinschauen, um zu verstehen, warum das System genau das erkannt hat. Irgendwie das Bier kaufen mit Windeln kaufen bei Männern korrigiert. Das erschließt sich hier nicht intuitiv. Das System hat trotzdem diesen Punkt gefunden, wo es gesehen hat, da passt irgendwas zusammen und man hat es hinterher erklären können. Aber dass man das hinterher erklären kann, ist nicht gegeben.
Ich kann jetzt nachvollziehen, was gerade gesagt wurde, wenn man es versteht, dann sagt man, das ist ja eigentlich nur Programmierung. Weil alles, was wir jetzt hier besprochen haben, sind immer sozusagen Softwarelösungen für ganz konkrete Probleme. Das verbinde ich natürlich nicht so sehr, also ohne jetzt Ahnung vom Fach zu haben, sondern so gefühlt ist das für mich nicht Intelligenz. Wenn du natürlich Daten irgendwie endlos analysierst, dann kannst du halt ein bestimmtes Problem klären, aber Intelligenz ist ja eigentlich sowas, was man dann auch auf andere Dinge...
Ich würde da noch ein anderes Projekt erzählen, das ist auch ein Projekt von Google, die also auch diesen Go-Menschen geschlagen haben. Bei dem Projekt ging es darum, alte Computerspiele zu spielen. Es gibt also so die alten Atari-Spiele, diese alte Atari-Spiele-Konsole. Und bei diesem Projekt ist also so, es gibt 50 verschiedene Spiele, so wie Pac-Man und so weiter. Und die haben ein System gebaut, das selbstständig lernt, all diese Spiele zu spielen. Also sie haben ein System gebaut. Und wenn sie das auf das Pac-Man ansetzen, dann lernt das nach einer Weile, Pac-Man zu spielen. Und wenn sie es auf das andere Spiel mit den Puddeln ansetzen, dann lernt es nach einer Weile, das Spiel mit den Puddeln zu spielen. Das heißt, da ist irgendwie so eine gewisse allgemeine Fähigkeit, irgendwie findet das Ding raus, was es machen muss, um bei diesem Spiel zu gewinnen. Und es bekommt nur das Feedback, ob es gerade gewinnt oder nicht. Und den Rest muss es selber herausfinden. Da ist irgendwie so ein bisschen was, was so ähnlich wie Intelligenz aussieht.
Aber nur ein bisschen, weil es ist ja alles sozusagen ein Bildschirm, auf dem sich Dinge bewegen und die dann irgendwie einen Highscore geben.
Genau, das sind alles noch Spielwelten sozusagen. Aber es ist nicht so schwierig, sich vorzustellen, dass man statt einem Bildschirm dann ein Bild von der Videokamera nimmt und das ganze System in einem Roboter drin steckt. Und statt zu lernen, wie das Videospiel funktioniert, lernt ein bisschen größere Versionen von diesem System dann, wie die Welt funktioniert und läuft da drin rum.
Oder es steckt in einer Drohne, in einem autonomen Kampfroboter.
Um gleich mal das deprimierende Szenario aufzumachen.
Ja, da gibt es nämlich auch noch einen schönen AI-Fail. Also ich will ja jetzt hier nicht Schwarzmalerei betreiben, aber man hat ja das Militär auch irgendwann mal versucht, Panzer automatisch zu erkennen, die im Wald irgendwie fahren. Und dazu haben sie in einem neuronalen Netz relativ viele Bilder gegeben, welche mit Panzer, welche ohne Panzer. Und dann haben sie es mal in der Realität ausprobiert und dann hat das immer irgendwie geschossen auf Gegenden, wo keine Panzer standen. Und die haben sich das dann genauer angeguckt und haben dann gemerkt, oh shit, wir haben ja auf den ganzen Bildern, wo die Panzer drauf waren, da hat ja die Sonne geschienen und auf den ganzen Bildern ohne Panzer, da war es bewölkt am Himmel. Das heißt, das neuronale Netz hat jetzt halt gelernt, den Schlagschatten von den Bäumen zu erkennen und guckt überhaupt nicht auf die Panzer.
Okay, die Sonne ist ein Panzer, so viel hab ich jetzt gerade gelernt. Aber jetzt habt ihr gerade so eins von diesem Bass, was immer wieder auftaucht, neuronales Netz. Was ist das?
Also es gibt Leute, die laufen rum und sagen, das sind Methoden, die so funktionieren wie das menschliche Gehirn. Und daran ist, da ist ein bisschen was dran, weil diese Methoden komplizierte Muster erkennen können. Also wenn ich rumlaufe und mit dem Auge irgendwo hingucke, dann ich sehe, ob irgendwo ein Tier auf der Straße steht oder so. Das fällt mir leicht. Und es war bis vor gar nicht so langer Zeit relativ schwierig, einem Computer dazu zu bringen, dir zu sagen, was in einem Bild an Gegenständen zu sehen ist. Das war erstaunlicherweise ein total schwieriges Problem, an dem wir 50 Jahre lang rumgebastelt haben. Und neuronale Netze sind Verfahren, mit denen man solche Mustererkennungsprobleme lösen kann.
Aber was sind neuronale Netze?
Was neuronale Netze sind, ist ein Stapel von einfachen statistischen Klassifikatoren. Genau.
Was?
Das haben wir zwei unverständliche Antworten gegeben.
Das kriegen wir hin. In der Tat. Oder ich sag mal, was das im Vorstellungsmaus heißt. Normalerweise gibt es Computer. Diese Computer können Dinge berechnen. Zum Beispiel kann man Datenbanken reinwerfen, was so eine Art große Tabelle ist, die man sich noch vorstellen kann, also sehr gegenständlich. Alles, was ihr so sagt, klingt so nach, in diesen riesigen Tabellen gibt es halt Dinge, wenn man die genug analysiert, die gehören dann irgendwie zu sammeln. Wer Bier kauft, kauft auch Windeln. Wenn ich neuronale Netze höre, denke ich, okay, das ist halt nicht mehr irgendwie so ein so ein Ding, sondern da gibt es irgendwie verschiedene Dinge, die miteinander kommunizieren und dann so.
Vielleicht die beste Art, sich das vorzustellen, ein neuronales Netz ist ein Computerprogramm, das du nicht selber programmierst, sondern das Durchrumprobieren so lange verändert wird, bis es in allen Beispielen, die du ihm gegeben hast, sich richtig verhält. Das heißt, du musst dir die Regeln nicht selber ausdenken, sondern es sucht sich eine mathematische Funktion, die deine Eingaben in deine Ausgaben überführt.
Es ist also ein Suchverfahren.
Mit dem was?
Ich bin ja nicht zufrieden mit euch, verstehe ich. Ich würde noch einen Schritt weiter gehen, dann ist es ein Suchverfahren. Ist alles, was KI ist, ein Suchverfahren?
Der nächste Schritt an der Stelle ist jetzt natürlich, dass wenn du dein neuronales Netz in der beschriebenen Art und Weise trainiert hast, dann hast du eine erhöhte Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wenn du Daten reinfütterst, die du so noch nicht gesehen hast, die aber in das generelle Muster passen, dass sie dann trotzdem richtig erkannt werden.
Das ist aber keine Eigenart von neuronalen Netzen.
Nicht per se, aber es ist nicht das, was nur neuronal Netze auszeichnet, aber es ist auch die Eigenschaft neuronalen Netzen, die hat dieses Generalisieren dann beherrscht, dieses Generalisieren auf den Eingabemustern, die jetzt zum Beispiel AlphaGo erlaubt hat, Züge zu spielen, die den Großmeister zwar überrascht haben, aber wo man hinterher sehen konnte, das war ein sehr guter Zug als Beispiel.
Aber jetzt habt ihr immer nur noch beschrieben sozusagen, was der Effekt eines neuronalen Netzes ist. Was ein neuronales Netz ist, weiß ich jetzt immer noch nicht.
Wie technisch hättest du es denn gerne? Also man könnte sagen, ein neuronales Netz ist einfach ein Funktions-Approximator. Ein was? Du hast einen Eingaberaum. In diesem Eingaberaum kannst du beliebige Objekte darstellen. Wenn du jetzt ein Bild hast, dann kannst du ein Bild zum Beispiel verwandeln in eine lange Sequenz von Zahlen. Wenn du ein schwarz-weiß Bild hast, nimmst du den Luminanzwert, also die Helligkeit an jedem Pixel, was dich interessiert, und hast du pro Pixel eine Zahl und die schreibst du in eine lange Wurst. Und in diesem Eingaberaum, also der Raum aller Zahlen, die deine Bilder repräsentieren, darauf trainierst du ein neuronales Netz. Und ein neuronales Netz besteht aus künstlichen Neuronen. Ein künstliches Neuron ist verbunden mit ganz vielen Eingabewerten. Und das rechnet die irgendwie zusammen, das macht die Summe und schiebt die dann noch durch eine Aktivierungsfunktion. Und am Schluss entscheidet es, feuere ich oder feuere ich nicht. Also gebe ich den Wert weiter oder nicht? Und das kannst du schichten und stapeln. Und am Schluss, was rauskommt, ist halt ein Wert, der sagt, auf diesem Bild war ein Hund oder auf diesem Bild war eine Katze.
Okay, ist das eine Netzwerk? Ja, so halb irgendwie. Also ein Netzwerk, aber ist das tatsächlich ein Hardware-Netzwerk? Oder ist das sozusagen Software, die man so modelliert quasi?
Meistens erst mal Software.
Ja, also ich würde gerne mal versuchen, die Magie rauszunehmen. Das klang jetzt alles sehr magisch. Und für diejenigen, die von linearer Algebra ein bisschen was verstehen, können wir es vielleicht in drei Sätzen entmystifizieren. Also ich würde bottom up vorgehen. Ich würde sagen, was ist ein neuronales Netz? Das besteht erst mal aus mehreren Schichten an Neuronen. Und was ist so ein Neuron? Dieses Neuron nimmt die Inputwerte aus der darunterliegenden Schicht und multipliziert die mit seinen Gewichten. Es bildet also nichts weiter als das innere Produkt der Gewichte mit den Aktivierungen der darunterliegenden Schicht. Also es ist mathematisch gesehen einfach nur eine Vektormultiplikation. Also ich nehme diese lange Wurst von Eingabedaten und multipliziere sie mit einer langen Wurst, die meine Gewichte sind. Und summiere das alles aus.
Was sind Gewichte?
Gewichte sind, musst du dir das so vorstellen, für jede einzelne Eingabefahrt, die dein Neuron hat. Dein Neuron hat vermutlich irgendwie 25 verschiedene Eingabefahrte. Ein kleiner Drehregler. Und an diesem Drehregler kannst du algorithmisch dran rumdrehen, wenn du versuchst, Hunde in deinen Bildern zu erkennen.
Beim Lernen.
Beim Lernen, genau. Da drehst du algorithmisch an diesen kleinen Reglern rum. Wir müssen jetzt nicht genau erklären, wie das funktioniert, weil das irgendwie die Sendung sprengt. Aber du drehst da algorithmisch automatisiert dran rum. Das macht kein Mensch mehr, sondern das macht dann Algorithmus. Um dann hinterher bei dem Ergebnis deines neuronalen Netzes rauszubekommen, das ist jetzt ein Hund oder nicht. Ich hab meine Wurst an Zahlen, die geb ich rein. Und habe diese ganz vielen verschiedenen kleinen Regler, die halt wissen, ich muss diesen Teil der Wurst in diesem Neuron so verarbeiten und diesen anderen Teil der Wurst in diesem anderen Neuron so verarbeiten, dass ich hinterher die richtige Antwort habe, dass ich da einen Hund gesehen habe.
Aber ich verstehe immer noch nicht, warum da sozusagen verschiedene Dinge zusammenhängen müssen. Also warum das ein Netzwerk sein muss. Weil alles was ihr sagt, ich habe verstanden, man kann ein Bild als eine Zahl darstellen. Bilder sind Pixel, ein Pixel kann eine Zahl sein. Diese Zahl, also alle Pixel miteinander, komplett ist eine lange Zahl, die kann ich mir verahnen. Okay, aber das mache ich ja in einem Programm. Was ist sozusagen das Ding daran, dass es ein Netzwerk ist? Wir müssen mit der Erklärung warten, vielleicht könnt ihr auch darüber nachdenken. Wenn wir einen kleinen Song spielen, das Cloud von Luno und danach machen wir gleich weiter. Und hoffentlich können wir heute noch erklären, was ein neuronales Netzwerk ist. This Cloud von Luno, das ist Netzmusik, also Musik, die ihr runterladen könnt und auch weitergeben, weil sie unter einer Creative Commons Lizenz steht und hier im Chaos Radio Moon, das ja mitveranstaltet wird, vom Chaos Computer Club gibt's, Chaos Computer Club, gibt es immer auch den Nerd News verfasst vom Chaos Computer Club, heute genauer von Danimo und vorgetragen von Emily Ulbricht. Wer Probleme mit seinem Telekommunikationsanbieter hat, kann ab sofort kostenlos ein Schlichtungsverfahren bei der Bundesnetzagentur beantragen.
Gedacht sind diese Schlichtungen laut Bundesnetzagentur-Chef Hohmann als kostengünstige Alternativen zu langwierigen Gerichtsverfahren.
Bislang kostete eine Schlichtung eine Gebühr von mindestens 35 Euro. Diese wird ab dem 1. April durch das sogenannte Verbraucherstreit-Beilegungsgesetz abgeschafft. Weitere Informationen findet ihr auf bundesnetzagentur.de oder in den Shownotes.
Um Geheimnisse zutage zu fördern, braucht es nicht immer Whistleblower wie AdWordsZone.
Oft verraten sich Beteiligte leichtsinnig selber. In der Jobbörse LinkedIn beschrieb zum Beispiel ein Softwareentwickler in seinem Lebenslauf, wie die NSA seit den 90er Jahren Glasfaserkabel anzapft.
Dazu bringen U-Boote unbemannte Drohnen aus, die ferngesteuerte Glasfaserverbindungen so anzapfen, dass dabei keine bemerkbare Störung auftritt.
Auf Online-Jobbörsen verplappern sich ehemalige Angestellte von Geheimdiensten immer wieder.
Kurz nach den SnowdenLeaks kam heraus, dass auf LinkedIn-Profilen die Codenamen dutzender NSA-Programme zu finden waren, teilweise inklusive immer noch geheimer Details. Wer die Anti-Viren-Software des Anbieters Trend Micro installiert hat, hat es Angreifern leicht gemacht, wie der Google-Sicherheitsforscher Travis O'Mandy herausfand. Wenn ihr eine Website mit einem Rechner ansurft, auf dem Trend Micro-Software installiert ist, kann diese Website euren Rechner vollständig übernehmen. Auf diese Weise könnt ihr euch zum Beispiel sogenannte Verschlüsselungs-Druane einfangen. Auch wenn Trend Micro immer wieder unangenehm auffallen, auch andere Hersteller von Sicherheitssoftware stehen immer wieder in der Kritik.
So schalteten zum Beispiel einige Hersteller die Windows Firewall aus, obwohl die Produkt selber keinen vollständigen Schutz bieten konnte.
Was haben wir gelernt? Sich eine Anti-Viren-Software zu installieren macht den Rechner nicht unbedingt sicherer. Das war Emily Ulbricht mit den NerdNews. Vielen Dank.
Radio hat einen Namen.
Das Chaos Radio im Blumen auf Fritz ist schon eine Stunde alt. In einer Stunde haben wir noch und sprechen heute hier mit Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club und aus den mehreren Umfeld über künstliche Intelligenz. Und ich heiße nochmal herzlich willkommen Priska, Klee, Tobias und Dentor. Hallo und guten Abend. Und wir haben in der ersten Stunde geklärt, was KI kann, nämlich Menschen im Go-Spielen schlagen, auch im Schachspielen, das ist schon seit längerem. Das ab und zu so Dinge gibt es Schieflauf mit künstlicher Intelligenz und haben dann versucht zu erklären, was ist das eigentlich und wie macht man das? Und sind dann auf den Begriff neuronale Netze gestoßen. Und ich habe versucht, aus den verehrten Anwesenden eine Erklärung heraus zu pressen. Und ich habe es bis jetzt noch nicht so genau verstanden, weil ich habe was rausgekommen ist, dass neuronale Netze Dinge sind, die man Daten reintut und dann kommen die irgendwie raus und da kommunizieren einzelne Neuronen miteinander. Aber wie das genau funktioniert und das bei dem ganzen Thema KI irgendwie so, das wirkt alles so magisch. Also es gibt immer einen bestimmten Punkt, wo Daten reingeworfen werden und dann fällt ein Ergebnis raus. Und dann sagt Tobias, das sind einfach nur Suchergebnisse. Und ich habe trotzdem nicht genau verstanden, wie es funktioniert. Falls ihr das auch nochmal genau nachfragen wollt, könnt ihr euch gerne anrufen unter 0331 77 97 110. Und ich möchte es wenigstens noch ein einziges Mal probieren. Neuronale Netze, was ist das?
Gut, also ich finde es ganz wichtig, dass wir, bevor wir zu den Netzen kommen, erklären, wie funktioniert so ein einzelnes Neuronen. Ich habe ja vorhin schon gesagt, wir haben diese Eingabevektoren. Die sind grün oder blau, spam oder kein spam. Und der Algorithmus, der ein Perzeptron lernt, das ist so eine ganz geniale, ein Perzeptron ist jetzt so ein einziges Neuron. Dieses Perzeptron besteht im Grunde nur aus einem Vektor, der in eine Richtung zeigt. Also wir stellen uns einen Vektorraum vor und dieses, was ist ein Vektorraum?
Also eine Einzelinformation oder wie?
Nee, es ist ein Raum, in dem Punkte drin sein können, Datenpunkte. Und das Perzeptron zeigt jetzt in dieser, es kann einfach Daten separieren in Gut und Schlecht. Und das tut es, indem es eine Ebene durch diesen Raum legt. Du kannst dir das als ein Blatt Papier vorstellen und auf der linken Seite machst du mit Bleistiftpunkte rein und auf der rechten Seite machst du mit Füllerpunkte rein. Und das Perzeptron, das kann einfach, wenn es weiß, ob die Punkte mit Bleistiften oder Füller gemalt sind, kann es eine Ebene finden, die die Bleistiftpunkte von den Füllerpunkten trennt. Eine Linie.
Okay, also ich versuch's nochmal, ob ich's richtig verstanden habe, das ist auch ein ganz einfaches Beispiel. Ein Einsatzperzeptron kann im Zahlenraum zwischen 1 und 100 arbeiten und kann dann unterscheiden, die Zahl, die ich reingebe, ist über 50 oder unter 50.
Nein, das tut es mit mehrdimensionalen Daten. Das ist das eigentlich Interessante dabei.
Das könnte es tun.
Das war das maximal einfache Beispiel und das ist korrekt gesagt. Also du hast verstanden, was das einfachste Element tut.
Aber das kann man halt im mehrdimensionalen, also auf ein Blatt Papier benutzen, um eben diese Bleistiftpunkte von den Füllerpunkten zu trennen, egal wie sie verteilt sind. Also wenn die Bleistiftpunkte tendenziell eher links oben sind und die Füllerpunkte tendenziell eher rechts unten, dann wird die Ebene halt so schief, dass der Klassifizierungsfehler, wie man so schön sagt, minimiert wird.
Also sage, aber ein einziges Neuron unterscheidet tatsächlich immer hart.
Genau, also die Einschränkung von einem einzelnen Neuron ist, dass es nur diese eine Linie zeichnen kann. Die kann auch keine Kurven mehr machen oder sowas. Und wenn man halt für bestimmte Datensätze dann Kurven braucht, dann muss man neuronale Netze zusammenscheiden aus einzelnen Perzeptronen.
Also das Perzeptronen kann nur hart unterscheiden zwischen Ja und Nein. Und es kann nur eine Ebene, also eine lineare Separierung in die Daten einbringen.
Also das heißt, du sagst, ich gebe da etwas hinein und dann kriege ich von dem einzelnen Neuron die Antwort, okay, das gehört jetzt dazu oder das gehört nicht dazu.
Genau. Und der Lernalgorithmus, das ist das Schöne daran, der ändert diese Ebene nur dann, wenn eine Falschklassifizierung passiert ist. Und deswegen habe ich vorhin auch wieder gesprochen und gesagt, die lernen eigentlich aus negativen Feedback.
Also ich gebe einen Punkt in dieses einzelne Neuron rein, das Neuron sagt Bleistift und ich sage nein, das war Füller.
Ja, dann dreht es die Ebene ein bisschen und vielleicht wird beim nächsten Mal das dann richtig klassifiziert. Und es gibt da so eine Theorie dazu, die sagt, dass wenn die Daten linear separierbar sind, dann findet der Perzeptron Algorithmus eine solche separierende Ebene. Das ist bewiesen und man weiß sogar, wie lange es dauert.
Okay, und das ist ein Neuron. Und jetzt verknüpft man das.
Da lass ich andere sprechen.
Also zum einen nimmt man viele dieser künstlichen Neuronen und legt sie in einer Ebene nebeneinander, damit man viele kleine Separatoren hat. Damit kannst du aber erst mal nur einfache Muster unterscheiden. Also wenn du zum Beispiel ein Bild hast, dann könntest du in einer solchen ersten Ebene von künstlichen Neuronen erkennen, ok, da sind Balken, horizontale, vertikale Balken.
Also wenn ich ein Bild hab, kann man dann Pixel unterteilen? Ist dann quasi ein Neuron ein Pixel? Oder macht ein Neuron eine bestimmte Eigenschaft eines Pixels und ein weiteres Neuron macht eine andere Eigenschaft desselben Pixel?
Tatsächlich ist, ja, ein zweiteres. Und tatsächlich ist jedes Neuron mit allen Eingabepixeln verbunden und kann sich aussuchen, das links unten ist mir vollkommen egal, das rechts oben interessiert mich total.
Das sind die kleinen Drehräder, von denen ich vollgesprach.
Oder die Gewichte. Aber auf dieser ersten Ebene lernst du halt sehr einfache Muster nur. Zum Beispiel eben Balken, orientierte Balken.
Da ist ein Strich in dem Bild.
Da ist ein Strich in dem Bild, genau. Und was wir aber erkennen wollen, sind doch zum Beispiel Gesichter. Und deswegen hat man mehrere Schichten von solchen Naronen übereinander, weil du auf jeder Ebene höher komplexere Muster erkennen kannst. Also wenn du zum Beispiel auf der untersten Ebene Striche erkannt hast, dann kannst du auf einer Ebene drüber Kombinationen von Strichen erkennen. Und so weiter, bis du dann ein Auge erkannt hast und zuletzt ein Gesicht.
Und dieses eine Ebene drüber ist das, man programmiert quasi das einzelne Neuron und programmiert dann Regeln, wie ein Neuron mit anderen Neuronen kommuniziert. Und den Rest lernt das System alleine oder werden diese Ebenen übern...
Also die Architektur ist quasi vorgegeben.
Also Menschen überlegen sich, wie viele Ebenen baue ich auf und wie viele Neurone kommen in jene Ebene. Und die Gewichte lernt das Netz dann aus den Daten.
Okay, jetzt habe ich zumindest eine grobe Idee davon, was ein Neurales Netzwerk sein könnte. Vielen Dank. Wenn man sich jetzt zugehört und dachte so, okay, und das weiter lernen möchte. Eine Antwort ist immer Wikipedia. Ich weiß nicht, wie du sagen, wie gut der Artikel über neuronale Netze da ist, aber habt ihr irgendwie Literaturempfehlungen oder Link-Tipps oder Autoren, wo man sagt, okay, wenn ihr das wissen wollt, geht dahin, die erklären das gut.
Also es gibt, bei Wikipedia hat man oft das Problem, dass es sehr schnell absurd technisch und mathematisch wird. Da kann man Pech haben, wenn man dahin geht. Es gibt einen sehr intuitiven und mit vielen Bildern gemachten Blogartikel. Den findet man, wenn man nach neural networks und Chris Ola, O-L-A-H, googelt. Da findet man diesen Blogartikel.
Wenn ihr diese Sendung als Podcast hört, dann wird der Link auch in den Shownotes auf der Webseite stehen.
Genau. Aber sonst, wenn man nach neural networks Beginner Tutorial sucht und so weiter. Es gibt unglaublich viele Ressourcen dazu, weil das ein sehr stark in Mode gekommenes Thema ist.
Wir haben jetzt so lange nur über das Grundkonzept des neuralen Netzwerks gesprochen. Ist das sozusagen so, dass man sagt, oder die Anlassung gefragt, ein neuronales Netzwerk, ist das momentan gleichbedeutend mit, das ist KI? Wenn man heutzutage von irgendwas spricht, was konzident ist, dann sind es eigentlich immer neuronale Netzwerke?
Also sehr, sehr oft kommen neuronale Netzwerke als eine Komponente vor. So ein neuronales Netz an sich würde ich noch nicht als intelligent bezeichnen. Das kann keine Pläne machen oder sich Aktionen überlegen, die es als nächstes ausführt oder so. Das ist nur eine Komponente. Und es ist auch nicht das einzige Verfahren, was diese Aufgabe lösst. Das ist das aktuell erfolgreiche Verfahren.
Das ist quasi jetzt gerade Mode.
Also wenn wir über das Thema KI reden, dann denke ich als erstes mal an Computer-KIs. Also Computerspieler in Counter-Strike oder irgendwelchen Adventure-Games. Und die arbeiten, die benutzen oft gar keine neuronalen Netze. Oft sind das einfach nur Regeln, das sind einfach nur Skripte, die mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit abgespielt werden. Und deswegen dem Spieler den Eindruck erwecken, es handele sich um ein halbwegs intelligentes System. Weil da gibt es auch ein Feedback, eine Feedback-Funktion, das ist ganz interessant. Also der Computerspieler, der drischt auf dich ein, entweder mit der Hauptwaffe oder mit der Nebenwaffe. Und der zählt, wie oft es erfolgreich war. Und wenn sich also eine Strategie als nicht-erfolgversprechend herausstellt, dann verringert der Computer die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dieser Angriff erfolgt und er erhöht im Gegenzug die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines andersartigen Angriffes. Das heißt, es ist immer wieder eine Herausforderung für einen Spieler und das wird auch als künstliche Intelligenz wahrgenommen.
Ich finde, von mir nicht. Mir ist das nicht intelligent.
Das wollte ich auch gerade sagen. Computerspiel ist etwas, was ich sehr viel mache. Und da erkennt man sehr schnell die Grenzen, dass es halt genau nicht menschlich wirkt. Gerade wenn du Ego-Shooter sagst, ist der Unterschied, gegen Computergegner zu spielen und gegen Menschen ist halt total extrem.
Aber wenn du eine gut aufgedrehte KI hast, dann kann die viel besser spielen als ein Mensch. Ich weiß nicht, ob einer von euch mal Quake gespielt hat mit dieser Railgun. Da kannst du auf eine irre Entfernung Leute totschießen, weil die keine Dispersion hat. Weil die, wenn du genau genug zielst, einfach trifft. Und so ein Computergegner, der kann halt viel besser zielen als ein Mensch.
Ja, genau.
Also die sind nicht unbedingt schlechter.
Nein, nicht schlechter, aber nicht intelligent, nicht kreativ genau. Also es gibt natürlich Computergegner, die mich sehr leicht besiegen können. Aber das wirkt dann meistens nicht, dass es aus einem kreativen Spiel kommt, sondern das wirkt halt, weil sie die Ebenen sehr gut ausnutzen können.
Das Wesentliche daran ist ja, die können ja nur das. Dieses Ding kann ja dann nur Counter-Strike spielen. Aber die Frage, die hier gestellt wird, ist auch tatsächlich eine, mit der sich Philosophen beschäftigen. Ab wann ist denn ein System als intelligent anzusehen? Und es gibt auch die etwas einfache Definition, dass du ein System dann als intelligent ansehen kannst, wenn es für dich am besten dadurch vorhersehbar ist, dass du es quasi als Mensch betrachtest. Also der Lee Sedol, der gegen AlphaGo gespielt hat, der hat garantiert nicht versucht, einen Computer auszutricksen, sondern er hat es so gespielt, als würde er gegen einen Menschen spielen. Und das hat Daniel Dennett, der Philosoph, mal mit den verschiedenen Herangehensweisen bezeichnet, dass du ein System auf der physikalischen Ebene dir angucken kannst und irgendwann vielleicht noch verstehst, warum irgendwie, indem du den Pfad nachverfolgst, warum aus dieser einen Eingabe die andere Ausgabe gekommen ist. Aber vielleicht fährst du damit für dich selbst viel besser anzunehmen, dass du da einem Menschen gegenüber sitzt, der mit dir jetzt gerade Gruß spielt. Und genau, also diese Frage ist tatsächlich nicht so ganz geklärt. Ab wann bezeichnen wir etwas als künstlich intelligent, ab wann nicht. Und ich finde diesen pragmatischen Ansatz relativ eingängig, dass man sich irgendwie selbst fragt. Zum Beispiel, wenn dein Auto selbst fährt oder sowas, dann kannst du als anderer Verkehrsteilnehmer fährst du am besten damit, dir zu überlegen, da sitzt ein Mensch am Steuer. Oder dir vorzustellen, da sitzt ein Mensch am Steuer. Dann funktioniert das selbstfahrende Auto am besten. Ich glaube, damit hast du total gut erklärt, warum viele Leute diese Systeme so gruselig finden. Weil man nicht genau weiß, als was man es jetzt genau ansehen soll. Man kann es nicht so richtig als Computerprogramm verstehen, weil es teilweise halt Dinge macht, die man ihm nicht explizit gesagt hat. Aber man kann es auch nicht so ganz als Mensch verstehen, weil es sich doch noch irgendwie anders verhält. Und dann ist es irgendwie gruselig, so ein Zwischending. Das steckt da glaube ich mit drin, in der Definition, die du gerade gegeben hast. Sehe ich aus.
Ist es denn so, dass man, also das klingt für mich so, dass zumindest theoretisch, es gibt KI's, die von niemandem mehr sozusagen vorhersagbar durch Blick werden, auch nicht von ihren Erschaffern.
Ich glaube, das kann man so sagen. Also man versteht ziemlich gut, wie diese Verfahren im Allgemeinen funktionieren, die wir jetzt, also zum Beispiel, du hast neuronale Netze erklärt. Man versteht, was das einzelne Neuron da drin macht. Aber nachdem das neuronale Netz dann trainiert ist auf irgendeiner komplizierten Aufgabe, dann löst es diese Aufgabe. Aber man kann nicht mehr genau sagen, was für Schritte es macht, warum es diese Aufgabe jetzt löst. Ob es jetzt die Bilder mit den Panzern so und so sortiert, weil der Panzer sind oder weil die Sonne scheint, man weiß es nicht, auf welchem Weg dann das System die Lösung findet. Also es ist nicht so, dass die Forschung da nicht daran interessiert ist, das besser zu verstehen. Es gibt Leute, die arbeiten an Theorien, wie dieses Lernen funktioniert. Und es gibt auch Leute, die ganz pragmatisch einfach fertige neuronale Netze anschauen und so untersuchen, wie ein Gehirnforscher einen Gehirn untersuchen würde. Die geben also irgendwie Reize rein und untersuchen dann, wie irgendwo tief in dem Netz so ein paar Neuronen darauf reagieren und schauen sich das dann an und machen Schaubilder und so.
Also pragmatisch, Entschuldigung, ganz kurz, pragmatisch nur für dieses Beispiel. Du fütterst ein Bild rein und dann guckst du, welche Muster hat das neuronale Netz denn da drin entdeckt?
Also um die Frage zu beantworten, ja, es ist teilweise mysteriös, was die machen. Nicht, weil wir es nicht im Prinzip verstehen, sondern weil wir es im konkreten Fall, nachdem es auf eine Anwendung trainiert wurde, nicht mehr verstehen.
Also die Ironie, die mich gerade überfällt, ist die, dass ja, ihr habt ja vorhin gesagt, was ja auch sozusagen ein anderer Teil ist, dass es ja ein bisschen daherkommt, dass man versucht, den Menschen nachzubauen, also damit auch den Menschen zu verstehen. Das Einzige, was man geschaffen hat, ist also Maschinen, also Software, aber sozusagen eine Technik, die man jetzt auch nicht mehr versteht. Heißt das, dass Intelligenz letztlich für den Menschen nicht verständlich ist?
Das liegt nur daran, dass das jetzt diese ingenieursmäßig motivierten Verfahren sind. Die wurden halt entwickelt mit dem Ziel, dass man diese Probleme lösen wollte, wie zum Beispiel erkennen, was auf einer Bild ist oder selbst fahren der Autos bauen usw. Das muss noch nicht bedeuten, dass Intelligenz im Prinzip unverstehbar ist. Wir haben jetzt halt nur erst mal Systeme gebaut, die halt irgendwie ein bisschen unübersichtlich sind. Aber vielleicht können wir diese unübersichtlichen Systeme im Laufe der Zeit noch besser verstehen. Es ist ja besser, man hat ein unübersichtliches System, was man dann noch erforschen kann, als man hat gar nichts.
Naja, aber wir hatten ja schon ein unübersichtliches System, was wir erforscht haben, nämlich das menschliche Gehirn.
Ja, aber das kann man nicht auseinandernehmen.
Was ich mich natürlich frage, ist, dass es schwierig ist, das zu erklären, also die Magie, die in der KI passiert. Das liegt natürlich jetzt bei uns ganz konkret an der eingeschränkten Sendungszeit, an den wenigen Formwissen etc. Aber tatsächlich habe ich das Gefühl, in dem ganzen Thema gibt es immer diese Schwelle, wo es uns Magische kippt. Weil ihr auch sagt, im Prinzip haben wir gerade das Thema geschafft. Wir wissen sozusagen, wie das einzelne Neuron, wie es im Grundsatz funktioniert, aber dann wissen wir es irgendwann wieder nicht. Das heißt, wir haben ein weiteres System geschaffen. Jetzt hast du gesagt, na klar, bei dir kann man auseinandernehmen. Das stimmt, aber was macht man damit? Man baut vielleicht ein neues System, aber das wird dann auch wieder zu komplex und so weiter. Das finde ich schon sehr, sehr spannend.
Das kommt aber sehr stark drauf an, was für ein System du hast. Bei neuronalen Netzen ist es jetzt zufällig irgendwie schwieriger. Aber sagen wir, ich habe auch mal mit Agenten gearbeitet, die ein Motivations- und Emotionssystem hatten.
Softwareagenten.
Was sind Softwareagenten? Im Prinzip ein kleines Programm, das in Minecraft rumläuft und da Dinge tut. Das hat bestimmte Bedürfnisse gehabt. Zum Beispiel, dass es sich in angenehmen Temperaturen aufhält. Dann konnte man das beobachten und feststellen, das oscilliert relativ stark hin und her zwischen Wüste und Berggipfel. In diesem Fall konnte man nachgucken und hat festgestellt, es geht in die Wüste, dann wird ihm zu heiß. Dann denkt er sich, wo war ich schon mal, wo es mir nicht zu heiß war? Und geht dann schnell auf den Berggipfel. Das ist ein Fehlverhalten, aber wo du aufgrund des Modells, was verwendet wird, nachgucken konntest, warum hat es sich so verhalten? Es gilt nicht für alle Modelle der KI, dass man nicht in die reingucken könnte und die verstehen.
Es gibt sogar KI-Systeme, die komplett ohne Fasilogik auskommen. Was wir jetzt beschrieben haben, waren so Soft-Activation-Geschichten. Also alles mit viel Statistik und ich mittel irgendwas, und dann bilde ich einen Schwellwert. Es gibt auch Systeme, die direkt auf Regeln arbeiten. Also die versuchen in den Mustern, nicht irgendwelche Gewichte zu erkennen und die dann aufzusummieren, sondern die direkt Regeln ableiten und sagen, ich habe hier eine Regel gefunden, die ist in 95% aller Fälle richtig, also schreibe ich mir die mal raus.
Dass dann sagen, das ist so hart. Also sowas wie, wenn die Ampel rot sind, halte ich halt an. Also wie wir auch manchmal Dinge lernen.
Oder eben, wie gesagt, wenn ich Windeln kaufe, dann kaufe ich auch Bier, weil ich brauch's wahrscheinlich. Und dergleichen mehr. Und mit diesen Regellernern, da gibt es eben dann auch Methoden, also wie man bei den neuronalen Netzen einzelne Neuronen zu Netzwerken kombiniert, kombiniert man auch einzelne Regeln zu Ensembles aus Regeln, die man dann auf bestimmte Weisen miteinander kombiniert und deren Mächtigkeit erhöht. Und der Vorteil von diesem System ist eben, dass man die Regeln im Nachhinein noch lesen kann und was rein interpretieren kann. Das ist für Menschen immer sehr wichtig, dass sie in das, was sie vor sich haben, was rein interpretieren können.
Aber da kann man dann zu jedem Zeitpunkt sagen, das System hat jetzt so und so entschieden, dann kann das System immer sagen, das hab ich aufgrund folgender Regelstruktur gemacht. Dann kann man genau nachschlagen, wie die Entscheidung zustande kam.
Ja, beziehungsweise das Ziel des Lerners ist es sogar, Regeln auszuspucken, die für einen Menschen brauchbar sind. Das gibt es eben auch. Das ist dann das Thema Wissensentdeckung und Data Mining. Da ist also der Nutzen für den Menschen nicht der, dass das System irgendwas tut, sondern dass der Mensch eigene Erkenntnisse, auf die er selber nicht gekommen wäre, mit Hilfe von Computertechniken, mit Hilfe von diesem Suchverfahren, das eben viel schneller rechnen kann, als er suchen kann, generiert.
Gibt es da schon ein Beispiel, was auf diesem Wege rausgefunden wurde?
Ja, die Recommender Systems sind eigentlich das berühmteste Beispiel. Also Kunden, die diesen Artikel gekauft haben, interessierten sich auch für diesen Artikel. Und damit optimieren halt Warenhausketten ihren Umsatz. Also das, was ich erzählt habe vorhin mit dem Walmart und dem Bier, das hat tatsächlich eine Konsequenz gehabt. Und zwar hat Walmart dann das Bier neben die Windeln gestellt und die Bierverkäufe gingen hoch.
Das ist ja auch ein schönes Beispiel. Also gerade dieses Recomender-System, also quasi Kunden, die kaufen, kaufen. Also die Windeln kaufen, kaufen auch Bier. Ich kenne ja anekdotisch zumindest das so. Das funktioniert eher nicht. Also gerade wenn man sozusagen bei Amazon, wo das ja sozusagen am bekanntesten ist, guckt, das ist der, wenn er im Prinzip, wenn er, die letzte Sache, die ich mir angeguckt habe, muss ich, da zieht sich dann durch meine gesamte Empfehlungsliste, aber eigentlich ist nichts drin, was mich interessiert. Warum geht das so schnell schief?
Du hast zu wenig gekauft bei Amazon.
Ich wünschte, du hättest recht, aber das ist nicht der Fall.
Jemand anders benutzt dein Account nicht?
Nein. Also ist es sozusagen für die egal? Oder anders gefragt? Die empfehlen mir Kram, wo ich denke, das ist totaler Quatsch. Ist deren System zu billig oder ist das egal? Oder ist das irgendeine Logik, die ich nicht verstehe und die funktioniert bei allen anderen Leuten außer bei mir?
Vielleicht ist das der Punkt. Vielleicht haben alle anderen Leute diesen komischen Geschmack und kaufen den Kram.
Ich stelle die ganze Zeit noch auf unsere Sendungsvorbereitung und sehe da noch drei Schlagwörter, wo ich gerne fragen würde. Weil wir haben ja diese ganze Zeit drüber geredet. Also die lernen das irgendwie. Und jetzt gibt es anscheinend noch verschiedene Arten, wie man lernen kann. Hier steht Transferlernen, One-Shot-Lernen und aktives Lernen. Weil ich dachte, wenn Software lernt, gibt es halt dieses eine System, aber scheinbar gibt es verschiedene. Was ist da der Unterschied?
Das sind alles Sachen, die heute noch nicht so richtig gut funktionieren. Das sind also Einschränkungen von den aktuellen Systemen. Also, wenn man die Frage stellt, was können diese Systeme denn jetzt heute noch nicht? Also, sie können jetzt Go spielen, aber was trennt die noch von einem Menschen oder so? Dann ist eine Sache zum Beispiel Transferlernen. Das bedeutet, das System wird... Ach, was Quatsch. System, ich kann ja selber Transfer lernen. Ich hab in der Schule Wörter gelernt, mit denen ich Dinge ausdrücken kann. Und später kann ich die gleichen Wörter benutzen, um völlig andere Sachen damit zu machen. Das war gerade schlecht erklärt. Aber Transferlernen, das ist eigentlich eine total intuitive Sache. Also, dass du halt nicht nur eine Sache machen kannst, sondern dass du Teile von dem, was du früher mal gelernt hast, wieder verwenden kannst bei der nächsten Aufgabe. Sodass du bei der nächsten Aufgabe nicht wieder von vorne anfangen musst und von vorne lernen musst, wo oben und unten ist und was ist eigentlich hell und dunkel. Und ich hab zwei Arme. Sondern du kannst viel von dem, was du über die Welt weißt, immer mitnehmen für deine verschiedenen Aufgaben, die du machst. Und die Systeme, die es heute gibt, die sind relativ schlechter drin. Die werden trainiert auf eine bestimmte Aufgabe und dann machen sie halt diese Aufgabe. Und wenn du eine andere Aufgabe hast, kannst du zwar ein System vom gleichen Typ auf die andere Aufgabe trainieren. Und das ist dann auch toll, dass dieses System das selber herausfindet, wie es das macht. Aber du fängst jedes Mal von vorne an. Du fängst quasi immer mit einer Baby-AI an. Und man hätte eigentlich gerne, dass man den Trainingserfolg übertragen kann auf die nächste Aufgabe. Das ist also ein aktives Forschungsfeld.
Das ist Transferlernen? Was ist One-Shot-Learning?
Das ist quasi extremes Transferlernen.
Extrem Transferlernen?
Du hast als Mensch die Fähigkeit, dass ich dir ein Beispiel von der Sache sage. Ich zeige auf irgendein Tier, was da vorne steht. Es hat halt irgendwie komische Hörner oder so. Und dann kannst du mir weitere Beispiele davon zeigen. Das heißt, ich zeige dir ein Beispiel und du verstehst gleich, was die ganze Kategorie ist. Viele aktuelle AI-Systeme sind so, dass sie tausende Beispiele brauchen, bis sie verschiedene Kategorien von Dingen voneinander entscheiden können.
Das ist wie ein Panzerbeispiel. Man muss ganz viele Beispiele reingeben und muss auch noch dafür sorgen, dass sie richtig verstanden werden. Es gibt nicht mal einen, der sagt, hier, das ist ein Fuchs, und dann weiß das System sofort.
Genau, also eigentlich ist die Aufgabe unfair gewesen, die mit den Panzern. Weil wenn man einem Mensch Bilder von Panzern gibt, dann hat er vorher schon ganz viele Bilder gesehen von Wäldern bei Sonnenscheinen, von Wäldern bei bewölktem Himmel, von Wäldern in der Nacht. Und dieser Fundus an Wissen, den ein Mensch im Laufe seines Lebens ansammelt, den hat eine künstliche Intelligenz natürlich nicht, in dem Moment, wo du sie das erste Mal programmierst.
Ist das ein Speicherplatzproblem oder ist das ein Problem, dass die Algorithmen noch nicht so weit sind, dass diese Verarbeitung, dieses Transferlernen sozusagen stattfinden kann?
Na es gibt das Problem, dass einer künstlichen Intelligenz fehlt das Weltwissen und es gibt auch tatsächlich den Ansatz, dass man sich einen kleinen, babyförmigen Roboter baut, den man erstmal wie ein Baby behandelt, damit er wie ein Baby lernen kann, wie die Welt aussieht und wie das Dinge runterfallen, wenn man sie loslässt und dergleichen Dinge und wie ein Wald aussieht und sowas. Und es ist tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht, ob das nach wie vor aktuell ist, aber das war damals in dem Feld die Herangehensweise, wie man so eine AI anlernen kann, dass sie dieses einmal transferfähiges Wissen aufbaut einerseits und andererseits Stimuli, also Bilder oder sowas, in den richtigen Kontext einordnen kann, weil sie halt nun schon mal ein Wald gesehen hat. Das heißt, die Überlegung war halt, man weiß ja noch nicht, ob das stimmt, dass man tatsächlich ein Kind erziehen muss, wo eine künstliche Intelligenz rausguckt, damit es dann wirklich intelligent werden kann.
Das klingt auch wieder sehr gruselig. Also das finde ich tatsächlich sehr spannend, dass man die, also Fazit für mich bis jetzt zu sagen, man kann Intelligenz sozusagen anscheinend, zumindest derzeitiger Stand, nicht einfach bauen, sondern man ist tatsächlich irgendwie darauf angewiesen, man baut komplexe Systeme und die müssen dann aber auch lernen, weil man so ganz genau wie man sozusagen, wie man so ein Weltbild zum Beispiel instantan vorfertigt irgendwo reingeben sagt, okay, da ist es. Das scheint immer noch nicht zu funktionieren. Ich finde es sehr spannend. Wir werden gleich in der letzten halben Stunde nochmal darüber reden, nachdem wir die Grundlagen gelegt haben, was so der Ausblick ist, wann Moderatoren überflüssig werden, weil sie von einer KI ersetzt werden und noch viele andere Dinge. Vorher aber noch die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Am 2. und 3. September die Fritz-Deutsch-Poeten. Wieder live im Ifa Sommergarten der Messe Berlin. So lange es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten im Kombi-Ticket für beide Tage oder einzeln für Freitag oder Samstag. Mehr dazu fritz.de slash deutsch-poeten. Die Fritz-Deutsch-Poeten. Wenn mal wieder Sommer ist.
Mit Emily Ulbricht. Der Terror-Verdächtige Abdislam kann von Belgien nach Frankreich ausgeliefert werden.
Das hat ein Untersuchungsgericht in Brüssel entschieden.
Der 26-jährige Franzose war vor knapp zwei Wochen in der belgischen Hauptstadt verhaftet worden. Er soll bei den Terroranschlägen von Paris im November geholfen haben und war vier Monate lang auf der Flucht.
Bei den Attentaten wurden 130 Menschen getötet.
Abdislams Anwalt sagte, dass sein Mandant mit der Auslieferung einverstanden ist und mit den französischen Behörden zusammenarbeiten will. Der Flughafen in Brüssel kann nach den Anschlägen vor anderthalb Wochen wieder öffnen. Der Betreiber teilte mit, dass die ersten Passagiermaschinen übermorgen starten und landen sollen. Das müssten die Behörden aber noch genehmigen.
Am Brüsseler Flughafen hatten sich vergangene Woche zwei Selbstmordattentäter in die Luft gesprengt. Dabei wurde die Abflughalle stark beschädigt.
Außerdem gab es einen Anschlag auf eine U-Bahn. Insgesamt kamen 32 Menschen ums Leben. Am Montag sollen die ersten 500 Flüchtlinge von Griechenland in die Türkei zurückgeschickt werden.
Das sagten Mitarbeiter der EU-Kommission in Brüssel.
Damit würde die umstrittene Flüchtlingspakt mit der Türkei wie geplant umgesetzt werden.
Demnach sollen alle Flüchtlinge, die seit dem 20.
März in Griechenland angekommen sind, in die Türkei abgeschoben werden. Das Land bekommt dafür mehrere Milliarden Euro.
Außerdem sollen Flüchtlinge aus Lagern in der Türkei legal in die EU übersiedeln können.
Schwere Menschenrechtsverletzungen im WM-Land Katar. Dazu hat Amnesty International der FIFA noch mal schwere Vorwürfe gemacht. In einem Bericht der Menschenrechtsorganisation heißt es, Tausende Arbeiter würden auf den Baustellen ausgebeutet. In einigen Fällen könne man sogar von Zwangsarbeit sprechen. Amnesty wirft dem Fußball-Weltverband vor, zu wenig dagegen zu tun. Die FIFA reagierte zurückhaltend und erklärte, man wisse zwar von den Zuständen auf den Baustellen, vertraue Katar aber. Das Wetter Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Triebduo sind 6 Grad und in Spanau 8 Grad. Grünow und Neuruppinen melden 6 Grad, in Ludwigsfelde und Frankfurt Oder sind 7 Grad.
In der Nacht bleibt es bewölkt und im Süden von Brandenburg regnet es.
Die Temperaturen gehen dann auf 5 bis 2 Grad runter. Der Tag morgen wird netter als heute. Morgens kann es noch etwas regnen. Danach ist es aber überall sonnig und trocken bei maximal 13 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, Mitte in der Köpenicker Straße zwischen Engeldamm und Michael-Kirch-Straße. Gibt es einen Feuerwehreinsatz, da ist die Straße in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Und nach Brandenburg?
Vorsicht im kreismärkisch Oderland auf der B168 zwischen Waldsieversdorf und Münchenberg.
Gibt es Gefahr durch eine Herde Pferde auf der Straße? Fahrt hier also bitte besonders vorsichtig. Vorsicht auch auf der L40-Nutestraße Starnsdorf Richtung Potsdam. In der Ausfahrt Horstweg ist die POP-Feuerwehr im Einsatz. Und noch zwei Meldungen zur S-Bahn Berlin. Auf der Linie S2 fahren zwischen Blankenburg und Bernau von 22 Uhr bis Betriebsschluss Busse statt Bahn. Und nach einem Polizeieinsatz in Köpenick fahren die Bahnen auf der Linie S3 zu spät oder fallen ganz aus.
Davo's geht, euch ne gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr am Sonntagnachmittag zocken und lachen wollt, dann macht das doch bei den Sonntags Fritzen mit Kathrin Thüring und Jakob Lund und mit mir, dem Stimulator.
Immer sonntags ab 14 Uhr auf Fritz.
Genauer gesagt Chaos Radio im Blue Moon heute und wir sprechen heute über künstliche Intelligenz, aber das noch mit echten Menschen, nämlich mit Bento, Tobias, Clee und Priska. Hallo nochmal. Und wir haben also erst erklärt, was die Erfolgsmeldungen waren, was schon ganz schön schief gelaufen ist und haben grob versucht zu erklären, wie das überhaupt funktioniert, so eine künstliche Intelligenz. Und wir jetzt ganz zum Schluss noch ein bisschen reden, wo wollen wir denn damit eigentlich hin? Was wird denn noch? Und ich habe also das Klischee, dass man sagt, ja, künstliche Intelligenz, die können ja noch gar nicht so richtig viel. Ich habe jetzt neulich gelesen, eine KI hat den Geschichtenwettbewerb, also nicht gewonnen, ist da aber irgendwie in die Jury, in der Jury vorbeigekommen. Habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Also ich habe das mitbekommen und was da passiert ist, ist, dass die Wissenschaftler haben selbst einen Roman verfasst und die KI hat dann diesen fertigen Roman genommen und hinterher die einzelnen Paragraphen zusammengewürfelt. Und das ist tatsächlich, das klingt wenig beeindruckend und ist für mein Verständnis auch wenig beeindruckend. Es ist einfach nur so, wir waren die ersten, wir haben da irgendwie mal was mit KI gemacht und so, aber es ist tatsächlich nicht wirklich so anspruchsvoll und das kannst du halt auch mit einfachen, das kann halt irgendwie dein 15-jähriger, der ein bisschen PHP fahren kann, sowas auch bauen.
Also sie haben sozusagen einfach Textbausteine sozusagen dann willkürlich aneinander gereitet.
Nach meinem Verständnis ist genau das so passiert.
Das heißt sozusagen, das ist eher ein Armutszeugnis für die Jury oder die Textbausteine waren so belanglos, vielleicht war es auch Dadaismus. Okay, na gut. Ich muss natürlich jetzt fragen, gibt es also Maschinizierung hat ja damals irgendwie viele Jobs ersetzt, jetzt sagt man KI. Der Chatbot von Microsoft war Anfang dem Thema. Wird es irgendwann Radiomoderatoren geben, die KI sind?
Also wir können halt an der Stelle schwer über einen Ausblick reden, ohne kurz zu erwähnen, was denn dieser Touring-Test ist, von dem irgendwie viele Leute schon mal gehört haben können. Und zwar ist das ein hypothetischer, also ist das ein Test, den der Alan Touring damals vor ewig langen Zeiten mal vorgeschlagen hat, um rauszufinden, ob ein Computerprogramm wirklich intelligent ist. Und zwar ist das Setup, dass man eine Art Chat einrichtet, dass es entweder in einem getrennten Raum entweder ein Mensch an der Tastatur oder es ist ein Computerprogramm, was mit dem Prüfer in einem anderen Raum dann chattet. Und das ist eine nach wie vor bestehende Herausforderung für die Programmierung von künstlichen Intelligenzen. Da gibt es auch Leute, die da aktiv dran arbeiten, das endlich mal zu gewinnen. Diese Challenge mit einer natürlich programmierten künstlichen Intelligenz, die dann sich tatsächlich verkaufen kann als tatsächliche 16-Jährige oder sowas, wie halt da jetzt mit Tay so ansatzweise passieren sollte. Und da sind wir noch nicht. Also ich glaube, letztes Jahr hat irgendwie gerade mal die Runde gemacht, dass ein Programm, was vorgab, ein nicht englischer, also kein natürlicher Muttersprachler zu sein. Und ein 15-jähriger Junge in der Ukraine hat halt irgendwie drei von, was waren das, fünf Richter innerhalb von fünf Minuten überzeugt, dass es eventuell eine KI ist. Und das Chat-Log, wenn man sich das anguckt, da fragt man sich, was haben die denn geraucht? Das ist doch nie im Leben.
Wie war das? Ein Mensch?
Drei von fünf Menschen haben dieses Programm als, haben gesagt, da sitzt ein Junge auf der anderen Seite. Und da ist ein Programm da, was einfach nur durch schlechtes Englisch und vorgeschobenen geringem Alter diesen drei Leuten vorgegaukelt hat.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn du keine Interaktion zulässt, könnte man dich vielleicht ersetzen durch ein Chatbot mit richtiger Interaktion mit prüfenden Menschen. Also ist es erstmal noch schwierig.
Puh, sehr schön. Dann kann ich da noch eine Weile hier arbeiten. Das finde ich ja ganz beruhigend.
Allerdings gibt es schon Zeitungsartikel zu bestimmen, normalerweise Domainspezifisch, die von Programmen geschrieben werden, zum Beispiel Sportnuss.
Das kann ich mir natürlich vorstellen. Das lustige, da kommen wir jetzt zu Computerspielen. Bei den Fußballspielen wird ja immer sozusagen, das Einkwalitätsteam, immer sozusagen, wie gut sind die Kommentatoren, die in dem Fußballspiel eingebaut sind? Und da merkt man halt noch sehr deutlich diese Floskelwolken, die da sozusagen angegeben werden für bestimmte Spielereignisse. Man kann die schon erkennen. Aber wenn man sich dann ein richtiges Fußballspiel anhört, denkt man so, so groß ist der Unterschied eigentlich nicht mehr. Also gerade weil Sportkommentatoren ja auch dazu tendieren, immer wieder dieselben Sachen zu sagen. Okay.
Also eigentlich muss man ja, um ein Fußballspiel zu kommentieren, einfach immer nur den, den der Ball hat, bei Namen nennen. Und wenn der Ball in die Nähe vom Tor kommt, die Stimme heben.
Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen komplizierter, aber vielleicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung von Fußballspiel.
Wo will man denn noch hin mit der KI? Also was sind denn jetzt sozusagen Sachen, die man tatsächlich noch machen will?
Also es gibt halt, es gibt natürlich starkes wirtschaftliches Interesse, im Prinzip alles zu automatisieren, wo man heute in Menschen bezahlen muss. Also für jeden Job findest du irgendwo jemanden, der gerne hätte, dass er da eine AI hat, die diesen Job stattdessen macht. Und es gibt einige Aufgabenfelder, wo das halt durchaus realistisch ist, dass das irgendwann in den nächsten 20, 30 Jahren oder so tatsächlich passieren kann. Auch wenn es dann keine KI ist, die mit uns redet und eine Persönlichkeit hat oder so. Aber die kann ja vielleicht trotzdem Akten wälzen und ein Gerichtsprozess ein bisschen vorbereiten, helfen oder so. Das heißt, was man schon so ein bisschen erwarten kann, ist, dass halt die Arbeitswelt sich stark ändert. Es gibt eine Studie, was natürlich Kaffeesatzleserei ist, aber es ist eine Studie von zwei Oxford-Professoren, die zu dem Thema forschen und die haben am Ende die Zahl rausgekriegt, dass 47 Prozent der Jobs in den Vereinigten Staaten absehbar, also kann noch eine Weile dauern, Jahrzehnte, aber absehbar von Automatisierung betroffen sein könnten. Steht in unserem Text-Dingsbuch.
Kann man klar sagen, das sind Jobs, die bestimmte Dinge erfordern? Oder ist das einfach die Hälfte aller Jobs wird ersetzt?
Das naheliegende Beispiel, was vielleicht auch schon diverse Leute mitbekommen haben, sind ja die selbstfahrenden Autos, die in absehbarer Zeit, wenn da nicht ganz krasse rechtliche Hütten noch aufgebaut werden, die Fernfahrer ersetzen können werden. Und nicht nur die. Genau, und nicht nur die, das ist jetzt auch schon absehbar. Und diverse Science-Fiction Autoren malen auch jetzt schon die Szenarien an die Wand, dass diejenigen, die dann noch darauf bestehen, ihr Auto selbst zu steuern, ganz krass hohe Versicherungspolizen bezahlen müssen. Und sonst werden sie nicht mehr selbst an Steuer gelassen. Weil es ist auch heute schon so, so statistisch gesehen, sind die selbstfahrenden Autos weitaus weniger unfallanfällig als der Durchschnittsautofahrer. Und es wird einen starken politischen Willen auch in die Richtung geben. Also es gibt da verschiedene Strömungen. Die einen wollen die Fernfahrer nicht abschaffen und die anderen sagen, aber die Straßen wären so viel sicherer, wenn wir das tun würden.
Wie ist es denn eigentlich, es gibt ja im Science-Film auch das Klischee oder diese Vision des persönlichen Assistenten, der im Prinzip nur ein Computerprogramm ist. Wie weit sind wir davon entfernt? Ist das überhaupt etwas, wo man KI braucht oder will und wird daran gearbeitet?
Also wenn ich mir meinen Siri und mein Sprachdialogsystem von der Navi angucke, dann sage ich, wir sind da noch nicht sehr weit.
Das würde ich genau auch so sagen. Aber die Frage ist sozusagen, wird das kommen oder ist das eh illusorisch als Anwendung?
Also ich würde dem ein bisschen widersprechen. Ich finde das Ganze, also ich finde gerade Siri beeindruckender, als ich jetzt erwartet hätte. Also als jemand, der sich mit dem Thema auskennt. Ich habe damals im Studium selbst mal versucht, Spracherkennung und ähnliche Dinge zu machen. Und das, was dann halt irgendwie auf den Tisch geworfen wurde von den diversen Herstellern, das fand ich persönlich relativ beeindruckend. Aber ich sehe natürlich auch, dass da jetzt noch ein großes Potenzial herrscht. Da ist definitiv Verbesserungspotenzial drin. Aber dass du irgendwann, also auch in absehbarer Zeit, in natürlicher Sprache dein Computer sagen wirst können, so mach mal einen Termin für morgen und so. Keine Ahnung, Kleintreffen oder so.
Aber das ist witzig, da sind wir wieder an dem Punkt, wo ich sagen würde, das ist für mich nicht künstliche Intelligenz. Also weil, also jetzt in meinem persönlicher Leben ist es so klar, ich kann in das Telefon was sagen und das wird in Text übersetzt und dann reagiert es auf eine Art und Weise, wo ich sehr genau sehen kann, ok, du hast jetzt einen Stichpunkt da rausgenommen und das war's dann. Und davon abstrahiert, ich habe ein Programm, wo ich sozusagen Freitext eintragen kann, irgendwie treffen mit CCC am 7.3. und der organisiert aus diesem Halbsatz in der Hinschreibe einen Kalendereintrag. Das ist aber für mich nicht KI, sondern der Assistent ist halt eher so ein Ding, eigentlich müsste ich mal vielleicht irgendwie dennächst wieder mal im Club vorbeischauen und dann sagt er so, naja, irgendwie vielleicht gehst du nächsten Donnerstag hin, da ist irgendwie auch diese Veranstaltung und das passt doch in deinen Zeitplan.
Also Leute, die diese Veranstaltung besucht haben, könnten sie auf die folgende Podcastshow besuchen, interessieren. Also die Bildung Blocks haben wir, wir haben die Spracherkennung, wir haben die Recommender Systems. Eigentlich haben wir das alles, aber im Endeffekt funktioniert es nicht anständig.
Es wird aber ganz klar aktiv daran geforscht und wahrscheinlich ist es auch noch viel stärker im Einsatz in gerade in so Ländern wie Japan, wo die Scheu mit KI's zu interagieren viel geringer ist als hier in Europa.
Ja, also ich komm ja selbst blöd vor, wenn ich in mein Handy reinrede und da ist niemand, der mir da gerade zuhört. Und ich muss ja, das ist ja auch der Trick mit Siri gewesen, das ist ja absichtlich vermenschlicht, sodass ich mich dann traue mit meinem Handy zu reden, um meinem Handy zu sagen, so hier, find doch mal raus, was morgen für ein Wetter ist. Und es, gerade in Japan, Japan hat noch andere Features, also Japanisches sehr leicht zu parsen, also sehr leicht für einen Computer in einzelne Bausteine zu übersetzen, den man dann mehr Bedeutung entziehen kann als jetzt zum Beispiel Deutsch. Aber das nur so am Rande. Und für mich, ich hab mich halt damals in meinem Studium viel mit diesem ganzen simplen Problem beschäftigt, wie kann man Sprache erkennen? Das kannst du halt auch nicht runterprogrammieren, das musst du auch erlernen, das musst du den Computer erlernen lassen. Und gerade da sehe ich, dass auf jeden Fall so kommen, dass ganz krasse Fortschritte gemacht werden.
Du hast es gerade bei den autonomen Autos schon gesagt, naja, wenn da nicht irgendwie noch rechtliche Hürden kommen. Eine spannende Frage bei KI ist tatsächlich auch, also beim Auto gibt es ja dieses Klischeebeispiel, was, wenn das autonome Auto etwas überfährt. Aber generell ist es ja so, wie wird denn es eigentlich mit der Verantwortung? Also sagen, Dinge, die eine KI tut oder entscheidet, wer hat denn da die Verantwortung für?
Im Moment natürlich der Fahrer. Also wenn wir von diesem Teilautom, von diesem hochpilotierten Fahren sprechen, dann ist es natürlich der Fahrer. Da gibt es einen Disclaimer. Aber prinzipiell, wenn Autos vollautomatisch unterwegs sind, hat der Hersteller die Verantwortung.
Ich meine, sagen nicht nur auf Autos beschränkt, sondern generell, wenn man sich das vorstellt, sagen Dinge, also KI, wir nehmen 50% unserer Jobs, sondern in diesem Job läuft was schief.
Also wäre es dann daran schuld, dass ich keinen Job mehr hab, oder?
Nein, nein, wer ist daran schuld, wenn in diesem Job was schief läuft? Ist es der Programmierer?
Fragst du nach dem Status Quo oder?
Ich frage beides, also tatsächlich nach dem zu sagen, wie ist das jetzt gerade, also bei Autos ist das der Hersteller, aber auch, was für Ideen gibt es, wie man damit umgeht in Zukunft? Also werden KI's irgendwann juristische Personen?
Man begibt hier ja wieder so ein bisschen den menschlichen Fehler, also man begeht den menschlichen Fehler, dass einzelne Missgeschicke unbedingt einen Schuldigen haben müssen. So sind wir Menschen halt nun mal verdrahtet. Wir wollen halt irgendwie gerne Finger zeigen. Aber wenn man halt auf der anderen Seite hingeht und sagt, das ist halt einfach nur ein dummer Unfall, dann müsste man jetzt irgendwie mit leben. Wir müssen jetzt einfach runterkommen von dieser ganzen Wer hat hier fahrlässig gehandelt? Einfach so sagen, ok, dieses Unglück ist einfach nur als Resultat von unglücklichen Begleitumständen entstanden. Und dann müsste man es einfach abhaken und gut ist. So ein bisschen wie wir zum Beispiel Unwetter behandeln. Unwetter, da können wir halt tatsächlich nichts dran machen. Wir können keinen Finger mehr zeigen.
Das ist aber schwierig, weil du sagen würdest, da müsstest du ja vorher eine Gesellschaft geformt haben, wo Unglücke halt passieren können und wo es niemanden doll weh tut.
Oder wo du eine Versicherung hast gegen KI.
Da haben wir glaube ich auch unterschiedliche Meinungen.
Genau, das ist vielleicht auch ein Thema für deinen Rechtspodcast. Sich das ganze Thema da mal aufzurollen. Ich glaube, wir kommen hier heute nicht auf einen gemeinsamen Nenner, was das anbelangt.
Da ist es aber eigentlich doch völlig klar. Also wenn ich ein Produkt kaufe und der Hersteller sagt, das kann automatisch fahren und dann fährt das gegen eine Wand, dann gibt es das Produkthaftungsgesetz. Also die Verantwortlichkeiten da sind eindeutig geregelt. Und in Amerika ist es auch gar kein Problem. Da finden sich dann Versicherungsgesellschaften, die kalkulieren halt einfach das Risiko und berechnen ihre Prämien darauf. In Europa ist das noch nicht möglich, weil es hier die Wiener Konvention gibt, die einfach vorschreibt, dass ein Fahrzeugführer zu jedem Zeitpunkt für sein Fahrzeug verantwortlich ist. Er muss es auch übersteuern können. Da werden die Hersteller dazu verpflichtet. Und darum entwickeln sich die, das pilotierte Fahren entwickelt sich in Deutschland sehr viel langsamer als in Amerika aus genau diesem Grund. Ich persönlich würde sagen, da steckt ein Unterschied in der Philosophie dahinter. Und eventuell haben wir natürlich auch das Interesse, dass unser Logistikmarkt, der sehr personalintensiv ist im Moment, dass wir den nicht komplett entvölkern wollen, weil wir dann wieder ein gesellschaftliches Problem mehr hätten. Wir hätten sehr viele arbeitslose Fernfahrer, Taxifahrer. Die ganze Intensivmedizin könnte man um 10 Prozent, 15 Prozent zurückfahren. Und da stünden ganz viele Leute auf der Straße.
Du meinst, es war jetzt weniger Verkehrstote?
Vor allem weniger Schwerverletzte. Man muss ja sagen, die Verkehrstotenzahlen sind in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren, glaube ich, um die Hälfte gesunken. Von 8.000 in Deutschland auf 4.000 pro Jahr. Groberichtzahlen. Es gibt inzwischen mehr Selbstmorde als es Verkehrstote gibt. Aber der niedrigen Zahl an Verkehrstoten steht eben noch eine sehr hohe Zahl an Schwerverletzten gegenüber. Der Punkt ist einfach der, die Menschen, die sterben, nicht mehr am Unfallort, weil wir eine sehr gut funktionierende Intensivmedizin haben, weil wir ein gutes Netz an Rettungsdiensten haben. Und wenn man einen Menschen innerhalb von 10 Minuten auf die Intensivstation bringt, dann kann der schon fast gar nicht mehr sterben. Also so viel Blut kann man gar nicht verlieren. Und selbst wenn man 10 Minuten lang Hirntod war, kriegt man den Typen irgendwie wieder fit. Und dann bleiben halt Pflegefälle zurück. Und das sind zehnmal mehr als es Verkehrstote gibt. Also da gibt es unter der Oberfläche schon noch einen größeren Teil des Eisbergs. Die volkswirtschaftlichen Kosten der Automobilität sind sehr hoch.
Aber was du sagen möchtest, es ist moralisch auf jeden Fall geboten, dass wir selbstfahrende Autos haben, weil das so viel sicherer ist, selbst wenn es ab und zu mal schief geht. Ich stehe mir dem auch zu.
Okay, dann sagen wir, dass beim selbstfahrenden Autos, bei den persönlichen Assistenten, wissen wir nicht so genau. Ich würde zum Schluss von euch persönlich noch wissen, was für euch jetzt gerade in dem Thema für euch aktuell wird, womit ihr euch vielleicht selber beschäftigt. Oder ob ihr vielleicht selber sozusagen kleine KI's für euch baut, die in eurem Alltag was machen. Vielleicht können wir bei Bento anfangen. KI sozusagen jetzt ganz aktuell bei dir, was wird da in Zukunft eine Rolle spielen? Oder was findest du gerade spannend?
Also ich finde gerade spannend, mir ist vor kurzem die Idee gekommen, dass man zum Beispiel E-Mails nicht unbedingt in Spam und Nicht-Spam klassifizieren braucht. Also nicht ausschließlich, sondern dass man genau den gleichen Ansatz auch für zum Beispiel Themenbereiche verwenden kann. Dass meine E-Mails dann automatisch sortiert werden in Dinge, die ja mit dem CCC zu tun und Dinge, die haben mit der Uni zu tun und derartige Dinge.
Also das...
Letzte Woche habe ich genau über sowas.
Wir müssen uns mal zusammensetzen. Du willst halt nicht selber diese Filter schreiben, sondern du willst, dass ein System lernt, wie die...
Genau. Ich klick dann sozusagen meine Mail und sag halt so, okay, das hier war jetzt Uni und bitte lernen jetzt mal, dass das... Merkt ihr mal, dass eine E-Mail, die so aussieht, kommt von der Uni und ist für Uni relevant und eine E-Mail, die so aussieht, ist irgendwie für Hobby relevant. Und die Erwartung ist ja, weil halt Spam-Filter heutzutage vergleichsweise gut funktionieren, ist, dass die sich auch anwenden lassen auf diesen Themenbereich.
Okay, und du willst nicht nur, dass das thematisch anso tät wird, sondern vielleicht auch so eine Wichtigkeit? Diese Mails solltest du jetzt lesen, die anderen können warten.
Da gibst du mir eine schöne Idee, dass es dann ein zukünftiges...
Falls du das gelöst hast, bitte Bescheid sagen. Ich hätte das auch gern. Tobias?
Ich habe im Moment keine eigenen Projekte. Ich hatte mal eins. Da ging es um die Extraktion von Webseiten-Inhalten. Da habe ich so einen Regel-Lerner gebastelt. Ich mache da aber nicht dran weiter, weil man hat ja immer dieses Rechte-Problem. Sobald du irgendwo aus einer Webseite die Daten rausziehst, kommen die Verlage und verklagen dich.
Aber was findest du spannend beim Thema Chaos? Also gibt es irgendwas, was du jetzt beobachtest?
Ja, also ich finde einfach dieses Thema, dass man Regeln lernen kann, die für Menschen wiederum interpretierbar sind. Und da doch eine, ja, eine gute Statistik dahinter steckt. Das finde ich, ist ein sehr mächtiges Verfahren. Ist ein sehr mächtiger Ansatz. Man kann damit viel machen. Aber ich habe im Moment konkret keine, keine Projekte in der Richtung laufen.
Also ich versuche gerade da hinzukommen, dass ich dran forschen kann, was diese neuronalen Netze innen drin machen. Also ich interessiere mich dafür, wie die funktionieren und wie die Aktivierungen da drin so aussehen und wie man die dazu bringen kann, dass sie verständlich sind. Und möchte auf jeden Fall schauen, dass ich zu den Leuten gehöre, die da dran mit basteln und die wissen, wie das funktioniert und das vielleicht auch irgendwie verständlich halten können oder so. Also die Vision, dass wir total mächtige KI's haben und niemand versteht sie, die finde ich selber auch ein bisschen gruselig. Also ich verwende meinen Spamfilter zu Hause nicht, weil ich dem nicht über den Weg traue. Priska?
Also an Projekten habe ich so mehrere kleine, die mal nebenherlaufen. Primär auch um sich mit Technologie bekannt zu machen. Eins ist zum Beispiel einen kleinen Chatbot zu trainieren, der Tweets im Stil eines Freundes von mir ausspuckt. Ein anderes, was jetzt gerade auch durch AlphaGo wieder aktuell geworden ist, ist halt mal zu gucken, ob man selber nicht so ein Go-Programm trainieren kann. Und weil ich selber Go spiele, ist das umso interessanter, weil ich dann natürlich dagegen spielen möchte. Also da gibt es immer wieder so kleine Projekte nebenher.
Alles klar. Dann vielen Dank, dass ich heute die Zeit genommen habe, um heute versucht, mir und uns zu erklären, was Künstliche Intelligenz ist, wie es funktioniert, wie man es vielleicht lernen kann. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das war das Chaos Radio. Jetzt hab ich die Nummer vergessen. Verdammt, ich wollte sie mit noch... 221, stimmt, 221. Das nächste Chaos Radio findet ihr nicht bei Fritzstadt, sondern direkt beim Chaos Computer Club Berlin in der Marienstraße 11. Ist dann Ende April. Und wir hören uns hier auf dieser Stelle in zwei Monaten wieder. Hier kommt jetzt gleich Flo Heiler mit dem Night Flight. Ich würde vorher noch hinweisen auf den Podcast. Der erscheint im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de und dann irgendwann am Laufe der Woche auf chaosradio.ch. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich danke euch fürs Zuhören und habe noch eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.